the freedom flew is apparently working
as much as the establishment tried to
deny its existence and there was some
technicality to the uh technically the
truth things to what they were saying
there was no as my understanding very
large and organized sick outs or
protests but there were some small
protests we did see there were many
individuals taking paid time off taking
sick time and we're seeing this in
police departments as well now in
chicago they're threatening police
officers if you try to take time off
you're being blocked if you try to
retire instead of getting the vaccine
they will go after your benefits
southwest however has lost one major
battle though the vaccine mandates are
still there they are now saying they
have ended the plan to put people on
unpaid leave if they are pending an
exemption not exactly getting rid of
their vaccine mandates so a little
correction in the headline we put up but
still they're slowly backing down with
chicago police
this is where it gets crazy a judge's
has ordered the president of the police
union to stop encouraging people to defy
the mandates
the beast is a shaken it's getting
scared and we gotta talk about that we
gotta talk about what happens when you
demonize defund remove the police
because we can take a look at the crime
in san francisco and we've got someone
here to actually talk about how
progressives are destroying uh cities we
have author michael schallenberger you
want to introduce yourself oh yeah
thanks for having me i'm the author of
apocalypse never and also the new uh
book san francisco why progressives
ruined cities right on so you're the
perfect person to talk about san
francisco being ruined
absolutely it's uh i just was looking at
the news just now and apparently they're
now offering rewards uh funded by
private individuals to solve some of the
crime cases
it's pretty absurd um hundred thousand
dollars i'm hearing yeah wow wow maybe
that won't do anything
but it's a private individual trying to
do something you know yeah i mean it's
just uh we're dealing with the breakdown
of civilization i mean it sounds
hyperbolic but civilization requires
that that laws aren't forced it requires
that uh
people
you know uh that there be consequences
for behaviors that are incompatible with
city life i talk about how the current
d.a was proposing to
basically just reimburse people whose
car windows had been smashed in
i mean what could go wrong right i mean
stores closing you got i mean when you
when you get a poop department you
should really reflect on your leadership
instead of being like we have a problem
with human waste i have an idea let's
create the poop department problem
solved
maybe some something else is going on
you know maybe that's a symptom of the
problem if people compare people will
come and they see the tents and they see
the people um including the definite
public defecations very famous and they
will compare it to like shanty towns and
poor countries i've lived in brazil uh
been in shanties i know favelas i've
been in very shiny towns in poor parts
of the world india
it's different san francisco is the
richest country one of the richest
places but even even in the favelas uh i
didn't see people taking dumps on the
stairs or the sidewalks like people
people all lived there and it was like
yeah i saw pretty bad conditions i saw
those channels they have the hill that
go down because they don't have a
consumer and just you know their waste
goes in there but they it's all going in
the same place the craziest thing i saw
was
someone's tortoise broke out of their
apartment
and i was like yeah they were i gotta
tell you man
going to a brazilian favela and seeing
the conditions and being like wow it's
bad and then going to san francisco i'm
like wow it's worse so that's something
we'll talk about all that we also got
luke yeah before we begin i wanted to
tell our loving viewing audience to
always trust the science no matter what
because you know they're never wrong you
should never question it the scientific
method is sort of like a suggestion and
our carefully curated selected highly
paid scientists who have conflict of
interest and connections to big
industries never lie to us and oh i also
have a a cloth on myself which uh you
could you could exclusively hold on
there luke let me let me look at that
what ddt no flies on me thanks to ddt
well there are no flies on that baby
clearly see cigarettes were recommended
by doctors yes that nursery water you
have there is still for sale today at
walmart hold on hold on what's that
what's that one asbestos well my
understanding is that asbestos is only
bad if you're trying to remove it and
and as it ages and cracks uh glyphosate
i'm not super familiar with that one
well there's a big lawsuit with monsters
sugar's bad don't eat sugar exactly so
yeah so this is just the random cloth
that i have on that you could also
exclusively get on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com and at the
same time support me being here so uh
thanks for having me thanks for coming
luke hey i was just michael were just
talking before the show we both lived on
coal
in san francisco over there by hate
street so i think i've got a little bit
of the similar maybe perspective of what
you're experiencing you were talking
about the guy screaming outside it might
have been the same guy
different year
very likely very possible old famous
screaming joe
wildly over i thought it was overpriced
when i was there in 2016 it was three
thousand dollars for a one bedroom which
with the most i'd ever paid way beyond
way beyond anything else and uh got
offered to buy mushrooms and weed every
day walking down the street wow
and then there's golden gate park and
all the people sleeping in the park like
a two blocks away or three blocks away
there's a big difference between
well i'll just put it up i'll just we'll
get into it poop department yeah there
we go indeed yeah so san francisco
sounds like it started beautiful and
then some super progressive policies got
into place so i'm really looking forward
to talking about that this evening and
we will but before we get started my
friends we have the sponsor that you
know and love biotrust go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you can
secure your supply of keto elevate mct
oil powder c8 it's the best of its
medium chain triglycerides never clumps
hormone and corn free that's i didn't
realize that no added junk so um as you
may have heard i just told luke that
sugar was bad i haven't been i haven't
eaten sugar i mean you get sugar in your
diet all the time but for the most part
i've cut out all the processed sugars
breads all the weird garbage food fast
food gone i've been eating like meats
i've been eating veggies i've been
eating way better man do i feel like a
million bucks and i love taking this
stuff the biotrust stuff we're huge fans
i mean you guys know that we shout out
biotrust we have like three different
things but it's because we genuinely are
like dude we really do like this stuff
like i'm i'm drinking the other thing
right now yeah me too put in everything
but uh this is really great stuff and
you know i i'm i'm basically i i'm not
doing like a harsh keto
but i'm getting most of my calories from
fat which is basically keto and i'm not
like you know mapping
anything like this but i love putting
this in my coffee i do a lot of cream i
do a lot of this stuff so again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com if you would
like to get the wonders of the keto diet
they say you get a 60 day money back
guarantee the healthy oh i have the
wrong one pulled up okay well anyway
i don't have the actually you know what
no i can still read this because they do
some cool stuff it's mctc8 oil powder
and for every order today they're going
to donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org today
biotrust has provided over 5 million
meals to hungry kids so please help them
hit their goal of 6 million meals this
meals this year
now this is no clumping as i mentioned
you will also be getting free shipping
on every order 51 of free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their new e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin actually i think it's the
collagen one we you know we promote so
much of this stuff but seriously go go
check out eat right well.com and um just
the the best thing about the sponsors
like biotrust and the other people other
other companies that sponsor the show is
they're willing to get behind the work
we do that's the most important thing
support the companies that are
supporting us we talk about how all
these companies are woke and doing all
these bad things well here's the company
that is doing something good if this is
what you're looking for check it out and
also here's a company you can support go
to timcast.com become a member and uh
right now we have a a live auction for
members to bid to get two tickets to the
event this saturday and we're gonna be
doing an auction every day and the
auction will sort of end randomly
don't rely on the timer that's on the
site because we don't want people to try
and just like sit there and like jam the
butt in the last minute so we could end
it right now and whoever bid is going to
win maybe we'll end it early
we don't know when we'll end it but
we're going to be auctioning off 10
tickets in total so there'll be five
different auctions and then i think the
last one be friday the event will be
saturday i know it's really short notice
for a lot of people but
we're just sort of winging it uh but as
a member you're gonna support our
journalists help us do more work and
it's greatly appreciated and uh that
being said don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
and uh let's jump into the first story
southwest airlines from cnbc southwest
drops plan to put unvaccinated staff on
unpaid leave starting in december
southwest scrapped a plan
to put their unvaccinated workers with
pending exemptions on unpaid leave after
the december 8th deadline both american
and southwest require their new hire
employees to show proof of cover 19
vaccination before their first day
large airlines are federal contractors
and subject to to a biden administration
order that requires their employees to
be vaccinated or receive an exemption
for medical or religious reasons now i
can respect the the exemptions for
medical and religious reasons the
problem is a lot of these companies are
just outright denying them no matter
what but this is a different case here
because there's reports of southwest
executives literally going around the
company asking people to please get the
exemption paperwork please fill it out
either for medical or religious purposes
they want so there's been an effort that
people are reporting that that they want
them to get these exemptions but this is
a huge announcement this is big i mean
they're pretty much announcing that
they're not going to be going along with
this tim you disagree with the uh
disagree disagree here but they're not
going to fire employees or in other
words put them on unpaid leave if they
don't get uh vaccinated they're not
going to do that that's a huge step
to me that has been demonstrated through
the freedom flu through all the protests
through all the demonstrations and
through all the massive disruptions that
we saw a couple days ago
the people opposing the mandates are are
gaining ground so this is a battle being
won but the war is still very of course
100 and here's what you've got to
understand when they say new hires are
still under the vax mandate they're
basically going to appease those who
currently work they're saying well
doesn't affect me anymore so i'm good
yeah and then new employees will have to
be mandated so what happens in 10 20
years the vax mandate stands we'll see
how long the vax mandates are going to
be implemented i definitely agree with
you a lot of people think they're going
to be temporary as long as kovid's going
to be around but as me and you know and
a lot of other people know this is a
long game it's not going to be ending
anytime soon it benefits too many people
it benefits too many billionaires for it
to stop but this is still a major
victory because the workers united here
came together and said hey we don't like
this policy we don't want it
go ahead i mean there were some protests
but we basically just saw people
disorganized being like nah exactly was
scarier to this company yeah southwest
is like we're gonna do this mandate oh
biden's making us do it and then a bunch
of employees just called in sick well
they knew they didn't organize they knew
forcing this would be worse for them
than not forcing it so this realization
that's the big story to me and that's
why i led with it that's why i've been
talking about it all day because this is
this is huge and there's going to be
reverberations of this all over the
place because now people know that their
voice actually matters when they come
together and they speak up together as
long as they don't back down exactly and
because because i i i genuinely think
most people the smartest thing they
could do was oh only new hires have to
be vaccinated
because then people who already hired is
going to be like
i'm good yeah later down the line that's
going to have its effects doing it right
now exactly so the vaccine mandate's
there this is an attempt to redirect
but it's probably still going to happen
it's probably still going to happen and
i'll tell you i really don't think that
the vaccines are the are the goal of the
mandate as you know people who listen
probably have heard me say a million
times because if you look at the chicago
police they're like if you try and
retire right now instead of getting
vaccinated we will take your benefits
we'll go after your benefits so very
clearly
they're just trying to force people
you know it's about the mandate not
about the vaccine part of it
uh also it's also important in that
specific case that a judge actually put
out put a restraining order on the
chicago police union chief that's
barring him from talking about the
vaccine publicly so this is a major
fight that's happening between the
police union the mayor of chicago and
this is not just in chicago there was
also police and firefighters today in
seattle that decided that they were
going to feed the homeless because they
were fired from their public service
jobs and they came out they went on the
steps of city hall took off their boots
left them there at city hall so there's
been a lot of different demonstrations
there's been a lot of big protests in
california a lot of people took their
kids out of school today because the
kids are mandated to be vaccinated and
they took them to a protest and there
was protests all over california saying
no we're not going along with these
mandates here's the things interesting
about southwest is that initially they
denied there was any kind of sick out
right right not happening
then all of a sudden the ceo comes out
and i we didn't we didn't want to do a
mandate biden made us do it and it's
kind of like why are you bringing up
mandates i thought the narrative was
that there was no you know that there
was no protest or anything about this so
they're clearly trying to now blame you
know uh joe biden but i'm wondering
michael what you think about
you know do you think trump would have
done something similar is this an issue
of progressives enacting policies that
are damaging to business and first
responders
i mean i at this point honestly what
freaks me out is that we've had such a
morale hit for the police in the united
states over the last year and a half
ever since the george floyd protests you
know we've lost you know a lot of these
police forces are understaffed right now
one of the things that i became very
was i was so surprised to find was that
the evidence of the importance of police
because i come from the left and so i've
always been somewhat skeptical of the
police
as part of the criminal justice
establishment but
the evidence that police prevent
homicides is just really strong and the
relationship between cops and potential
killers
just interacting with them every day in
the neighborhood very strong evidence
that works and so after 2015 after the
ferguson protests there was a pretty
sharp increase in homicides
one of the police chief in ferguson said
we're calling this the ferguson effect
because we think that both the cops are
pulling back from their policing and the
criminals are more emboldened
a lot of people on the left dismiss that
but we saw it again after the george
floyd protest last year
so clearly anything that um
that would basically dampen the morale
of police right now i think would
contribute to increasing crime
i mean it's just at the federal level
federal contractors federal employees
right
so it's
i don't know
is it just a direct correlation between
this is affecting the morale of the
officers or is this just failed policy
i mean we we i i
i'm a little bit i'm not on the fence on
this one i mean i'm vaccinated i think
vaccines are important i also think that
this issue is sort of that there's no
real explanation of what the end game
here is you know like how long are we
wearing masks for what is going to be
the deal with vaccine requirements
forever hasn't felt like we've had a
proper conversation about it um
i mean we do all the time and you know
the funny thing is
15 days to slow the spread has quickly
turned into nearly two years of harsh
restrictions mandates requirements
and
there's one prediction right now that
what's going to happen is
there will be a wave of fake vaccine
cards we've already seen some stories
and then all of a sudden you're hearing
the media people want digital passports
and they've already started making them
and then what really happens is a social
credit system
so they'll they they track more than
just your your vaccine like the one of
the reasons i'm i'm very much opposed to
this is they're they're trying they're
they're trying to use something that
most people find reasonable like getting
a vaccine i've got a ton you know i've
traveled all over so i just had to get
all these cards and you know when you go
to venezuela you need one and then
they're going to use that as they're in
to get you to carry your passport what
are they doing in new york you need your
id as well as your your medical card
well for a lot of people it's going to
be easier just to download the app
what's the app going to do the app's
going to track you in many many
different ways it's going to give the
government access to data that you know
only facebook has for instance and
shouldn't yeah so that's
well for me this is a big loyalty test
because a lot of officers who are
skeptical of the federal government who
want bodily autonomy who
think that they should have the right to
decide what is right for them there's a
lot of people who are vaccinated who are
against the vaccine mandates that are
still not even uh talked about widely
and publicly but there's a big sector of
these individuals out there so you know
we had a guest on a couple days ago that
said it's very easy to fake a lot of
this compliance a lot of these passports
and the people who are standing up the
people who are vocal or deciding to do
it on principles are deciding to do it
on morale and that's why seeing a lot of
these officers being purged a lot of
these officers being fired only will
help i believe the federal government in
the long run because they'll have more
compliant officers that will always do
what they want them to do no matter what
the consequences are and you always
start with something little and you keep
escalating it that's why we started with
you know just just two weeks to stay
home and then masks and then vaccines
and then second vaccines and then
passport systems and now booster shots
and then it's only going to get worse
from here unless the american people
stand up and say enough is enough we're
not going along with this and that's why
i think this southwest story is so big
it deserves a lot more
mentions and someone in the comment
section wrote that southwest decided to
do this because of the weather
conditions which i thought was
absolutely hilarious because that was
their initial line gensake said that
nothing existed that that this wasn't a
protest nothing was happening here well
obviously it was because why did
southwest change their major decision
here so these are going to have
far reaching implications not with just
with the police not just in the
corporate world but this is i think
deliberately done as a loyalty test to
see who's going to obey government the
most
and so your vision is basically we
should just you know basically have no
vaccine requirements no vaccine mandates
no max no mass requirements and just
make it like the flu shot in other words
if you want to get the flu shot you get
the flu shot same thing with coronavirus
yeah i i certainly think so we had a
really interesting conversation you know
ian asked about the the morality of
mandates like what if you had ebola
there's a good question and i'm like it
is tough i think with like an airborne
ebola with like this massively high
infectivity and you'd you'd like
it would self-regulate in a lot of ways
but ultimately regardless of whether or
not it does
i think
even with if that is the case we
shouldn't have mandates it should
self-regulate people should say i'm
concerned about this i will protect
myself but now all of a sudden we're
getting just the argument changes every
single time it comes out right first you
know fauci has said has gone back and
forth on masks i think two or three
times he he went back and forth on
double masking a couple times then the
cds he said where double masks and i
think a lot of people at this point are
just like when you get a fauci coming
out who can't give you a straight answer
but he keeps being touted and championed
eventually people just say enough
one of the biggest issues with with uh
the mandates is it's forcing people to
disclose medical conditions it's forcing
people to disclose private personal
details and if you're concerned about it
you need to assume the risks of your
life to go out and live and work from
that from the beginning one of the
problems we've seen with uh with cobit
is that we've decided to do a
one-size-fits-all approach to literally
everything hey the the people above 40
are the highest risk factor so let's
lock down everything including schools
and now we're in a major economic crisis
which is only being exacerbated by
ridiculous joe biden policies and
ignorance and people judge being on
vacation so it's they're really good at
making things worse maybe we should have
had a surgical approach where we said
okay if you're in a vulnerable
population we'll do special
accommodations we'll do what we can to
have skeleton crews keeping the economy
running so we don't just shut everything
down but we went one size fits all now
we're doing the same thing and you'll
have people who have
very deep religious or moral convictions
as to why they're not interested in this
notably the the the use of fetal cells
in the experimentation process for the
pfizer vaccine and johnson johnson uses
fetal cells for the growth of the virus
to produce it i can certainly understand
why a lot of people are like you cannot
force me to to take something like that
and then you have medical conditions in
which already in new york there's no
exceptions for medical conditions and
many of these businesses are saying
oh your doctor said no we reject that
that logic and so i'm seeing stories of
we had this woman i believe it was from
espn who said that she's trying to have
a baby with her husband and for that
she's been recommended not to get i
believe that's what it is well she says
she's not going to be in the vaccine and
they said we don't care whether you want
to have a kid or not there have been
there have been a few stories of women
who have said their doctors advise them
not to get the vaccine while they're
currently or about to you know try and
have a kid even though
i think the fda said it's it's safe for
women who are pregnant their doctor
still gave them personal advice based on
maybe their blood pressure
and now because of the fda because of
the establishment these women are being
told choose to have a kid or quit your
job like this whole thing is completely
broken that's why i'm like it's bad
across the board and where do you stand
what about things like uh measles uh
vaccines that are mandated for kids
before chronovirus obviously that's
what's going on or polio what about
those vaccines yeah so those are
particularly different but there's
there's an interesting overlap i would
oppose in in some respects vaccine
mandates in that area however we're
talking about vaccines that have been
tested for for decades
for you know uh some of the production
of some of these is 20 30 years and they
were these mandates were all implemented
through long
legislative processes as opposed to the
mayor said do it or else the president
says do it or else and now people who
are trying to get you know legitimate um
exemptions are being told no and now the
interesting thing that's
that this is all starting this is why
again man talk about bad policy from
democrats by mandating
this uh the coveted vaccine which is
just entering now the long-term trials
according to the fda insert for the
community vaccine you have people now
looking into mmr vaccines and the other
uh you know other standard vaccines and
they're discovering that not only do we
use fetal cells in the production of the
viruses from aborted babies we're we're
learning that they use that for like
ibuprofen and stuff so now you're
getting people actually starting to
challenge past
vaccine mandates which most of us didn't
have a problem with because we were like
long-standing research legislative
process legislative approach okay some
of us don't like that that's happening
but we agree we went through that
process now you have bill de blasio
being like do it or else with no
exemptions and so you get people who
have underlying medical conditions being
denied access to restaurants you have
people who are just concerned about
trusting the government namely a lot of
people in the black community billy
prempe made a great video talking about
why the black community is untrusting of
this they're being told they can't go
into these these businesses and now
because of the politics of it you
actually have republicans saying maybe
we should look into all of the mandates
and i'm like oh geez yeah i mean they've
been lying through their teeth about so
many of these issues they've been
flip-flopping they've been inconsistent
they've been censoring scientists
they've been censoring studies that have
been censoring actual real debate that
we never had about this faucio only does
softball interviews where they uh a
family-friendly show
pleasure him with words in many
different possible ways that i never
thought was even possible so so when
we're not even having a real
conversation when we're told 100
safe and effective and then we're
finding out oh three percent after a few
months and and and a lot of the data
that's still coming that we don't know
it brings up a lot more questions than
answers but but to kind of put the
question back on to you that you asked
tim how would you approach everything
well yeah i mean here's the thing guys
i'm not a great person to ask about this
because i
as soon as kovit hit i decided to work
on this book and that was like i'm flat
out on this book it was drugs crime
homelessness for the last several
hundred years
all i would say is i think it's
interesting because of course we have
two mental models of vaccines one is you
know as a parent i've got two kids both
have been through school already but you
know you have to get vaccines to go to
public schools but then you have a flu
vaccine you know every year we get the
the you know the shot for the flu
vaccine that's not mandate that's not
mandated so we have two different models
so it's kind of like is coronavirus
like polio and measles or is it like a
flu
obviously it's it's probably somewhere
in between yeah that's interesting long
covet is interesting because you've got
these lingering health effects and
that's why they're saying okay you know
maybe people should get this
i don't think you know i'll i'll put it
this way while kovitt is very obviously
serious and dangerous somewhere in
between i think is a good way to put it
i look at the data and i'm just like i
don't see this as being
on that level of mandating vaccines for
this but more importantly you know
you can choose not to put your kid in in
these schools you can go to private
schools you can go other places you can
homeschool to say you can't go to a
restaurant or hold a job is where we're
starting to get very serious because
right now this this is really where the
big dividing line is you could go and
get a job anywhere and they're not going
to demand your medical papers you know
they'll ask for your government papers
which already is you know pretty
interesting i think there should be an
argument about that but
now we're getting to the point where
it's if you want to get a job you have
to undergo a state mandated medical
procedure and that's where i'm like
yeah i'm not a big fan of that it's one
thing to be like this is a school
you don't have to put your kid in this
school you can find other ways to
educate your kid
now they're saying well go for you know
if if you've got
joe biden doing federal mandates if
you've got new york city doing citywide
mandates that's passing just you know
business mandates now as for private
businesses there's there's an
interesting argument here and i think
non-discrimination is where it becomes
uh there's a question about whether or
not a business like southwest could do
this so
uh does a business have a right to
discriminate on the basis of medical or
religious practices and the answer is no
overwhelmingly no i know that
conservatives uh
used to be on the other side of this to
a great degree like you know the famous
story of the baker the argument was the
baker was going to be was told he had to
write a message he didn't want to write
and said he ended up winning on free
speech grounds i guess but they still
harass him the left does
so i've always been on the side of if
you're using public spaces funded by the
public you have a right to serve the
public and provide public accommodation
to everyone you can't make up arbitrary
reasons to discriminate if someone comes
in screaming or threatening people yeah
by all means kick them out if someone's
got a disability i don't think you
should be able to to say no however what
are we seeing in for with a lot of these
companies they don't care about what
your doctor said what are we seeing in
new york in new york i called a couple
dozen restaurants who outright told me
they did not care if you had a
disability barring vaccination like
maybe you have guillain-barre syndrome
like the drummer from the offspring he
got kicked out of the band because he
could not get the vaccine due to
guillain-barre syndrome so this is where
people have just straight up been like
we have now violated the americans with
disabilities act we don't care and no
one will enforce it
i just not a fan not yet i mean it seems
like you have these two extremes between
australia and sweden
you know that have been sort of out
there as these two visible
mental models and
i mean what i can what i totally agree
with is is the idea that americans are
we're really bad at this is the points i
make in san francisco we're just bad at
the gray areas and a more surgical
approach to these things we just tend to
be it tends to be an on or off switch
for us yeah i i definitely agree with
that assessment because from the very
beginning there was so much
fear-mongering there was so much drama
there was so much emotional manipulation
that literally people shut down and
democratic politicians and also other
politicians said close down those small
mom-and-pop businesses police officers
ran around shut down those businesses
meanwhile the big multinational
corporations were allowed to be open the
whole time and i think to add to your
point that's why there was also a
sentiment against the police officers
that was very negative on the right
because of that and they didn't get a
lot of support when black lives matter
kicked up during that summer because
everyone's like these are the same guys
that kicked down my door and shut down
my business while allowing walmart and
costco to do whatever they wanted to so
where does this end it it doesn't
there's too many billionaires benefiting
from it it's going to proceed to lead to
a situation that we're seeing in
australia that we're seeing in italy
there's a viral video that i played in
my uh in my youtube video today of an
old grandma outside of a hospital and a
security guard is kicking her out
and he's like i want i want you know he
he wants the vax mandate she didn't have
the right paperwork she needed treatment
at the hospital she couldn't get it she
was told to go away and then she elderly
grandmother walked away yeah because she
didn't have the paperwork but she was
vaccinated i have no idea
about that but these are the vaccine
mandates you don't have your paperwork
you can't get food you can't you can't
get services that are basic human rights
services that shouldn't be denied to
anyone and this is going to lead to an
australian italian like situation
they're just ramping up they're just
ahead of the curve more than we are on
this phase and that that's where it's
headed unless people wake up here in the
united states
my wife and i
oh sorry oh sorry they're not actually
human rights like the right to buy
someone's food and stuff like that those
are actually those are civil some of
them are civil rights that are being
violated but i don't think any basic
human rights are at this point
you don't think human right humans have
a right to like trade with each other
is that is that is that one of the
constitutional basic humanities a state
coming in and saying you can't be a part
of society is that not a violation of of
human rights saying you can't get water
or well let's put it this way ian are
you saying that like if a black dude
went to a restaurant and they said you
are not allowed to buy from this
restaurant that's not a violation of
human rights if if a private company
wants to not serve someone yeah they
cannot serve someone so you're on the
side of like was that william f buckley
back in the anti-civil rights movement
in the 50s you would oppose martial but
if you're not do
not a company it's a government it's a
centralized big force that everyone is
forced to pay
that is discriminating against people
for their own personal medical decisions
it's not a private company don't
conflate it don't conflate it that way
it's a big centralized government
intervening in people's personal lives
saying you can't get water you can't get
food
but yes there's also a big government
intervening in private businesses saying
you can't deny services to someone on
these basis that's a whole different
argument than what ian's making now so
i'm on the side of civil rights the
civil rights protests where they said
you should not be allowed to
discriminate on the basis of race
national origin religion uh and then we
have the ada which is medical reasons
but you're more on the side of the
opposition like the the clan and and the
defendant i'm just saying that you said
that they were not being able to go to a
restaurant is a basic human right i
think it's not it's i'm saying civil
rights access to be able to get food and
water so so the example that luke was
giving was this lady who's trying to go
to the hospital now if you recall we
just had that story from dc where the
warden was held in contempt for not
following through with the human rights
of a prisoner who broke his risk health
care is not a human right if you're in
prison and you're being detained by
someone they have they have an
obligation a responsibility to make sure
you are not going through undue
suffering but shouldn't you be able to
like seek medical care like at least
have an opportunity to go in and talk to
somebody about getting right right
that's a human right is the freedom well
when you're prison you're you don't have
human rights i don't think they take
away away from you when you're in prison
for the moment you're saying that they
should be able to allow to buy the
service of medical care but not buy a
cheeseburger
no you don't have a right to medical
care that's a it's not a human okay i
just thought you were saying you should
have a right to seek that out
i i don't know no i don't know it's an
interesting
like ian you're an interesting guy
your human rights are not your right to
other people's services is my point so
so this is actually like i think ron
paul's position was very much the civil
rights act should have never have been
passed private businesses have already
discriminated i very very much disagree
with that i think that they're occupying
space in the commons that we pay for
yeah civil rights are like i paid my
taxes so the fire department has to come
and put my fire out that's a civil right
but you don't have a basic human right
you're not fighting you're getting it
now you don't have that so confusion you
don't have a basic human writer you're
confusing this you understand your human
rights are not a right to other people's
services of course but that's not that's
not what i'm arguing you said that
i'm arguing that your government
mandating a domestic permission slip
passport system where you have to get
their their uh you know acceptance in
order to go to the supermarket or in
order to get food and water is is a
violation of that that's the government
of this is how dangerous the disease is
i don't think so no of course it does no
i don't i don't think so i think i
literally just mentioned all of that
like
people need to self-regulate if there's
a very serious risk they need to decide
what risk they're willing to accept and
or not except if you know what george
washington inoculates his troops against
syphilis troops people who are who are
enlisted or conscripted polio's
crippling kids and and
like 20 to 80 smallpox is killing a
giant percentage of the population so
they mandate like at some point like
like i said angry horde won't get
healthy then you got what do you do you
know yeah stomp it with the boot
you know now you can now do that with
fat people
now do that now do that with people who
are what stp language do that with std
people who have stds dude you're such an
authoritarian
well there's
we've had this conversation before i
think there is a time and a place to
exert authority
my personal feeling is that when you
look at the according to sanjay gupta
99.5 recovery rate for covid and of that
point five percent that people aren't
recovering usually a lot of those people
are obese that it doesn't look like a
polio level uh problem
so if that then now we're talking like
ethics and is it ethical to to mandate a
vaccine
it's like you're arguing for freedom in
one argument and then fascism in another
sentence it's very confusing well
because it's just what john does though
they say you know oh you can't have free
speech if there's hate speech because
hate speech stops people from speaking
therefore banning hate speech is
actually free speech you see how they do
these semantic manipulations
like that's what what ian does someone
wrote in the comment section authorin
ian uh authority
and uh that we'll just defend i'll
defend ian because
i think i'm probably closer to your view
on this which is i mean obviously we
have restrictions on all sorts of
freedoms including freedom of speech
you're not allowed to yell fire in a
crowd that's not true no yeah that isn't
true you're actually allowed dl fire in
a credit theater yeah that was and that
was brandenburg the ohio i think where
they said that got overturned in the 60s
so that's um you're not allowed to
threaten people
uh you're not allowed to threaten people
with killing them that's illegal you can
report to the police and they'll be
investigated and it's not you're not
allowed to go up to people and be like
i'm going to kill you tonight and kill
all your family right directly that's
not legal direct threats though aren't
an expression of of uh opinion
you know you're you are allowed to say i
hope you die or i think someone should
do it to you yeah you're not allowed to
incite or direct you know how to say if
you keep tweeting that i'm gonna come
over to your house and kill you and your
family you're not allowed to do that
right um
so there is a restriction on speech and
i think i agree with you about the the
severity of this i think that i think
this issue does turn on the severity i
think if it were more severe
um you would be in a very you'd be in a
minority of people that were like hey we
shall self-regulate i just think most
people would be calling for i mean i
live in berkeley where people would give
me like the skunk eye for not wearing a
mask while walking in the nature trails
i mean it was like the demands for i
think one of the most interesting parts
of this phenomenon is that like the the
governance response is being demanded by
those local cultures right so it's like
right the swedes are jeopardy the movie
midsummer the whole movie i always think
about that because you're like those
guys are hardcore you know like they're
that's coming from within swedish
culture
um i mean there's obviously some
mediating influences like the kind of
government they have but you know
australia similarly they're very
moralizing in australia i find it's very
much like
this is a dangerous disease and
therefore we're going to like clamp down
on anybody and sweden when you when they
interviewed the the guy that oversaw the
cove response he was very much like look
you know it's very complex and there's
shades of gray and so i do think that i
think if this were a much i think if
covet were a much more deadly disease a
much more contagious disease and if it
killed a lot more young people then we
would have seen a more severe response
and
regardless of the kind of academic
arguments about it um
you know we would have been dealing with
a much more severe government i think i
think people would have been much more
accepting of mandates even in opposition
if the rates were really really high
like way higher yeah like initially we
thought like the new york times was like
six million in the united states might
die and so people were like 15 days all
right we get it yeah and then after a
while we're kind of like well yeah cuomo
killed 15 000 people and then you got
wolf and you got whitmer and you got
newsome they kept putting sick people in
nursing homes so their policies were
literally killing people and maybe we
need to stop doing the things we're
doing i think there's an argument to be
made here that with the more government
intervention there was the more problems
that came of it whether it's lockdowns
making billionaires richer than ever
making people poorer whether it's the
the lockdowns the mandates the
implications they have severe
ramifications and i would say those were
far off worse and i think there's
arguments to be made here than the
actual sickness itself and i think we
still haven't quantified the data we
still haven't found everything out but i
think 10 years from now or 20 years from
now when we find out the truth of what's
happening now i think a lot of us are
going to be shocked and disgusted maybe
history is written by the victors luke
it is but but mainstream media will
write what they write the the truth
somehow still has a way of coming out
and even though it's it's suppressed a
lot of the times it still finds a way of
seeping up somehow i mean i've just done
i've done i did joe rogan jordan
peterson now i'm doing the tim cast and
you know it's funny because um the
response so joe rogan has 11 million
followers it's the biggest media uh
presence i've had since in eight years
and eight years ago i did the colbert
report
um wow and when i went on colbert
reports like how many people watch this
and they were like a million plus maybe
another couple million on youtube and
streaming three million viewers of that
and that was huge like that was the one
like my my high school buddies were like
hey man you really mean you know like
that whereas now it's joe rogan
and he has a completely counter
establishment view of kovid
you know he's pro ufos he's pro
psychedelics i mean so in some ways you
go
you guys are pretty darn mainstream for
being supposedly marginal voices right
in the podcast as an author i can tell
you
this is so much fun for me i mean i get
to go on podcasts and you can actually
make a mistake and correct it
there's nobody playing gotcha with you
people are actually interested in what
you have to say two or three hours for
authors if you spend a year or two
slaving away on a book
and then you get to go on a podcast i
mean it's what we prefer and so
i find myself watching eighty percent of
my time watching tv is watching youtube
and watching podcasts like this so i
think you guys might be the victors that
write the the history maybe it won't be
something you're right have you guys
heard about ozzy media yeah i've heard
about it what is it no no i've never
heard of it no oh z yeah yeah
but i mean like the breaking news
no one has any ideas
yeah well you see what's going on with
new york these people are in a cult and
they're egocentric and so i love i
follow a lot of these journalists and
they're tweeting about the great scandal
that is the vaporware of ozzy media and
i'm just watching this like wow
talk about
thinking people care about garbage that
no one cares about this what happens
someone in new york who works in media
will write a story and they'll be like
guys did you hear about this and they'll
all get excited because they all play
inside baseball and then regular viewers
like regular readers are like on the new
york times like the hell are they
talking about
the politics of a media company i know
nothing about cares why is this news
they do that all the time
they don't so i think my favorite
example is sanjay gupta being like i've
never had a conversation more than three
hours it's like
amazing so these people don't talk
they they sit in rooms they read books
and then they watch tv and then they
might say a few words in passing so
weird i think you're told that i think
you're really on to something i mean i
um first of all i thought that the joe
rogan confrontation of sanjay gupto was
i mean i you know overstated his
is a turning point for me it was a
moment where
clearly rogan was right
and everybody was like rogan's right and
then cnn's back peddling but it felt
like a moment for me where because you
have this question of like who do you
trust
and i kind of go i end up i think a lot
of us are like we trust individuals now
yeah i trust and on different things
like i i trust barry weiss on cancel
culture you know i trust abigail
schreier on trans kids you know um
i don't trust barry weiss on cancel
culture yeah because she called tulsi
gabbard a toady for assad and didn't
know she was talking about now with all
due respect i think barry is cool and
everything yeah but
you know
it's like i mentioned with the with the
new york new york phenomenon where it's
like they're still very insular and very
much self-promoting and so even after
barry you know leaves the new york times
or whatever she's still cnn still has
her on brian stelter had her on and they
had a good conversation as a viral clip
on it but brian selter would never have
any real opposition a strong opponent to
anything he's done who could call him
out it's not going to happen that was
through a great clip that is going viral
right now and i think she surmised a lot
of the crazy things in our society very
well and very eloquently so i mean just
to have that i'm my reaction to it wait
wait wait i thought common sense was
banned on mainstream media right because
the mainstream media has their doctrine
has their agenda has their narrative
they're in an extremely small echo
chamber where they keep repeating the
same insane claims like for an example
uh colin powell passed away uh he was
double vaxxed he died allegedly of covet
he was also very old he also i believe
had cancer so so again you know we don't
know what happened i don't know i'm here
to say i don't know if it was the vax i
don't know if it was coveted i don't
know if it was cancer i don't know if it
was old age but the mainstream media
look at the narrative that they're
running cnn had the former surgeon
general on that was saying it was the
unvaxxed that definitely did it uh jeff
tedrich on on twitter said it's
definitely the unvacs that did this the
new york governor just came out with the
statement saying that history can't be
hijacked by the quote anti-vaxxers and
it's definitely anti-vaxxers that got
him sick how do they know are they
medical scientists do they know the
exact person that came into contact with
them do they have any evidence do they
have any proof that they have any data
no they don't they're running with the
same insane talking point that's
regurgitated from one prominent
establishment figure from another tool
from another sellout from another just
basic human being that is given a script
and regurgitating it back to you because
they pay them a lot of money doesn't the
fact that cnn had barry weiss on
suggests that actually they know that
there's i mean it looks to me like
there's a full-blown backlash underway
against cancel culture and that's just
beginning and cnn having barry weiss on
as a way of saying hey we know we took a
hit over the sanjay
gupta thing and the ivermectin thing
with joe rogan we're going to have barry
weiss on i noticed the new york times um
i just recently gave a column to my
friend john mcwhorter you know who's a
famous uh kind of liberal critic of
woke politics his new book is awoke
racism
you know i kind of look at that and i go
that's the establishment responding to
this long-form podcasting alternative
journalism i mean you got your start in
alternative journalism i mean i was in
the 90s alternative journalism was hot
but it's almost like
it's become where the intellectual
center of american right
life is now where you don't kind of go i
wanted i i watched a really thoughtful
segment no one says i watched a really
thoughtful segment on cnn they say i
listened to a really thoughtful podcast
with right tim cast or jordan peterson
or joe rogan i disagree with you because
after the rogan sanjay gupta thing cnn
doubled down and tripled down on those
same exact defunct talking points sanjay
gupta
came on effectively rolled back what he
had said on rogan when he was like they
shouldn't have said that he he went out
don lemon don lemon said it is horse
medicine he goes you're right and he's
like yeah you're right yeah yeah yeah
and a little bit but it's funny because
of course though then like then that's
talked about and so i don't i don't know
that cnn doing that helped its own
credibility any i think it probably
undermined do they have any credibility
is the question uh and i think that
barry weiss thing was a hiccup it was a
glitch in the matrix and they're going
to go back to their regularly scheduled
programming doubling down tripling down
on whatever the lie that they need to
sell the american people on is i mean
you might be right i mean we have this
debate because we um i would always have
this debate with my colleagues over
because you know we would point out look
people are becoming more pro-nuclear i'm
a big advocate of nuclear power
including for climate change but not
just for climate change and i've been up
against the vast majority of
environmentalists and boomers on this
issue
and we have seen a huge change in
attitudes on nuclear over the last five
years ten years that's why i went on
colbert for eight years ago i've seen
just a massive change
and at the same time people will respond
to me and they'll go well but the sierra
club is still anti-nuclear and it's like
well yeah but those are like the last
guys that are going to change their mind
so i mean peace will never change their
mind yeah greenpeace is not going to
change mine but you wouldn't measure our
success by being like you wouldn't be
like
well there's still a pope even while
acknowledging that catholicism has
significantly declined as a religion in
the western world over the last 500
years but there is the issue that
cnn could say something and then youtube
will panic and then implement policy
based on cnn's lies
that's very scary i don't know if you
guys have a view of it i was censored by
facebook
um
last year and it was very upsetting it
wasn't that because when you read about
censorship in the past and also some of
my favorite brazilian musicians were
censored you'd always be like that's so
those guys were badass can i say that
those guys were those guys were real
heroes but when you're censored it just
feels terrible like you're just angry
and upset my friend john stossel just
sued
um facebook over this and you just feel
angry and like you know that was
defamation though
yes he's suing over his information
because they keep being fake news and
it's an interesting thing though because
when they say they censored me and when
they censored me and they say michael
schellenberger said false things it did
feel defamatory to me i was like i said
true things and now you're saying i'm
saying false things gossip
yeah i mean it's um
what's disappointing is that you i knew
people at facebook i know people at
facebook and of course they were just of
zero help whatsoever you know and so you
just feel really alone and of course you
you're sort of ostracized and there's no
recourse there's no way of course to
even to even apologize there's no way to
even be
there's no way to even have retribution
in any any way shape or form or even
forgiveness you can appeal to the same
judge that sentenced you then that's not
an appeals process that's right exactly
so this is another layer to it that's
cruel and evil in so many ways because
the rules are very kind of generic they
implement them on some people and not on
others and then when they do hit you
they destroy your livelihood as they
destroy your reputation they they create
consequences that could have almost
everything taken away from you not just
your you know twitter page or tick tock
page i mean there are some people that
can't have an uber can't have an airbnb
can't have a bank account because of
their political ideas in this country
and so what do you do about that yeah
build decentralized uh internet
technology where you can you can also
appeal to a jury like the mind system if
you get go for it bitcoin is an answer
to the financial uh situation about
social media there's alternatives to
social media but again the big tech
monopolies with the help of government
control the major highways they were
able to build their infrastructure with
tax dollars these are not private
entities they have connections to
intelligence agencies they have
connections to governments they work
hand in hand they worked in tandem and
there's an argument of direct government
intervention but i don't believe that
the same government that created this
problem will be solving it anytime soon
i think it was what the democrats in
california were sending names to twitter
to ban yeah oh sure i mean so like okay
so i'm interested in glenn greenwald a
lot of people are interested in glenn
greenwald he became more interesting to
me in recent years um he's signed up for
this new platform
rumble rumble um
i have um i watch youtube i'm 50. so i'm
a lot older than you guys and maybe i'm
just too square but like i sit down and
watch youtube and i see you and i see
jordan peterson and i see joe rogan i
don't see glenn greenwald and then so
what do i got to do i got to go into my
smart tv and what reprogram it to get
rumble i mean it was a little bit like
what was the alternative to twitter that
was there for like five minutes parlor
last year parlor i mean and then they
colluded to destroy it yeah i mean so
you kind of go there's a problem because
you know we were all sold on these
platforms for their ease of use and the
idea that you would get to see i mean
that's what's so exciting about twitter
still is you still get to argue with
liberals and conservatives so now what
are we going to do we're going to have a
platform for liberals and a platform for
conservatives and it's all right
it's already what it is twitter twitter
is the the
the people on twitter who are prominent
are like center-right
people who are like staunch conservative
have are have been purged or banned
people who are like the far right was
nuked a long time ago except for like
some specific individuals
the far left however can call for
violence no problem
then you have the mainstream
establishment left can literally
advocate for violence tell people to be
violent advocate for people being thrown
into wood chippers like the covington
kids no problem
and then you could tweet us a joke learn
to code and get banned so we see
it's basically twitter is center right
to far left
and what that does is it shapes the view
of these journalists who think they're
centrists because they're in the middle
of that when in reality they're leftists
so what do you do about that we're
building up the fetiverse right now are
you familiar with it no it's a federated
network of networks basically so like
things like mastodon but basically it's
a you it the way we're doing it is
yeah yeah it's a social media protocol
so
you can create your own social media
platform where your content exists
and uh we'll use gab as an example you
know gab
heard of it gab is like the first uh one
of the first alternatives to twitter
because of the censorship they exist on
the fetaverse in that you can use any
fetiverse app and follow luke on gab so
luke's username might be like
lucadgab.com i don't know if luke is on
gab or whatever but then i could go on
you know
super
web and then say i'm gonna follow
lucidgab.com and see his posts from a
different website appearing on my feed
on this website so what happens is
there's no central authority to ban luke
okay but you have so you have like
almost a million twitter followers
yeah you do i have i have um one tenth
of yours
and so why would you want to go to a
platform where you and i would have the
same number of twitter followers i mean
or the same number of followers wouldn't
you want to maintain your status
superiority on a new platform i don't
care about the followers but all i do i
think a lot of people do like i i
certainly like in terms of the social
credit system it already exists it's the
number of followers you have on twitter
well no no no it doesn't depend because
the algorithm decides who sees what now
i tweeted a picture of a hairless rabbit
once it was weird
like you know i'll put it this way the
people there's there's there's a there's
two there's there's two different kinds
of people who become prominent you know
i was talking to a friend who does like
day trading stuff and i'm like there are
people who just want to be rich who will
eventually become rich because they want
to be rich but i think most people
become rich do it because there's a
something you're passionate about that
they pursue which leads them to being
well off i agree there are people who
have twitter followers because they're
genuinely interesting smart people or
they're you know
observant so they can see things for
other people and they're good followers
for that reason and then there are
people who try to manipulate and game
the system to try and gain followers and
are worried is my tweet getting enough
retweets or whatever
i don't care about any of that i don't i
tweet random jokes nonsense garbled
whatever because twitter is just
hilarious and so uh but for a lot of
people their twitter followers is really
important social capital for their work
i feel sorry for those people it's their
identity for many of them
so setting aside your your views of
those people that's a re that's a
material reality in the sense that it's
an economic reality for people so i
guess i'm raising it not to sort of
say is that good or bad but just to say
i think that's an obstacle to wanting to
migrate you know over to a different
social platform so we're we're on these
videos are on
on odyssey they're on rumble they're on
right yeah bit shoot yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and the thing about version website
you start building it out you you blast
out one post to the verse and it goes to
your minds account and your library
account and anybody else that wants to
federate so like it could blast out to
your twitter and like you can centralize
your own so funnel if if
self-centralized as the uh
this project
expands
you'll have more access to bigger
networks because you'll be hitting 50
instead of one
so
we use youtube but i cut down the amount
of content i was producing on youtube
substantially to try and focus on
building our own website so that we
could have a user base there
when uh we started doing the show we
were getting like a thousand viewers or
2000 viewers and if i was the kind of
person who was like we're not getting
enough clicks then we probably wouldn't
be where we are i want to do the show
because i had fun doing the show i
wanted to do it i make youtube videos
because i have fun making videos i make
podcasts because i have fun doing it if
i wanted to make money there's a bunch
of other stuff i could have done i have
friends who work for political campaigns
i'd make way more money you know i used
to work in non-profit fundraising and
all of a sudden i had these people
wanting to consult because i was making
so much money for a lot of these
companies and i hated doing it it was
awful just selling stuff and tricking
them
and so i just stopped doing it and then
a period of things happened occupy
happens i start working in this and i
enjoy doing it so i keep doing it when i
was traveling around filming breaking
news events
i don't know sometimes you wouldn't get
many views or make much money but it's
like i wanted to be there doing
something so it's true there are a lot
of people who are driven by a desire for
ego and that's why you get the new york
city establishment media because these
are people who are like i'm a worthless
human being but if i get hired by the
new york times then people will think
i'm cool
there you go yeah i mean i just i think
there's that but there's just also a lot
of people like you know for like a lot
of people like twitter is too complex
and facebook is like
about where a lot i mean it's facebook
is where a lot of people have arrived
and it's hard to see them it's older
adding apps using apps it's true
although yeah the young people are on
tick tock yeah although i even see young
people just reducing their social media
platforms to instagram yep instagram
yeah you know and so i i the idea that
we're going to go and make that work
more complex for people and that they're
going to we're going to get mass uptake
of it i'm skeptical you need to simplify
it it needs to be as easy to use or
easier than whatever's out there right
now i i i i disagree um
so we want to make it modular
without calling out any individual
company i can just tell you the the
strategy used by social media companies
to
become big is so obvious and
ridiculously easy
it's simple
what they've done again not naming any
individual company but more than one is
they'll create an app they'll advertise
it to high school kids
they will then give those high school
kids fake followers quickly and they
will give them fake likes and they will
give them fake comments and then all of
a sudden you have a new app called
superweb
and some kid shows up to his school and
they're like where do i follow you oh
dude i'm on superweb and they're like
what's that you're not on super web i
already got 10 000 followers and they go
dude john's got 10 000 followers and
they all want to download it because
they all want followers too
a bunch of companies have done this
some people have admitted to doing
things like this i think it was alexis
ohanian who said that in the early days
of reddit it was him and steve huffman
pretending to be different people to
make it seem like the site had users wow
otherwise no one would want to be there
right bigger companies discovered this
and started convincing young people they
were they were having they had followers
and then all of a sudden what happens
like you mentioned having that follower
account matters to people
so if someone's on twitter with 3 000
followers and then they download this
new superweb app and within two weeks
they have 10 000 they abandoned twitter
switch to super web because that's where
their core audience is so they think all
of a sudden now they're not producing
content other platforms they talk to
people where can i find you oh i'm on
super web i'm getting way more views way
more traffic
that then drives a mass exodus because
people think
you know fomo i'm going to go to the
other platform couple
new apps have used this strategy very
very effectively and i actually had this
conversation with um
with some political groups about wanting
to do an app like this this is like
seven years ago
and
it's painfully obvious that how it works
so if you really want to play those
games and do that
cheaters win but it seems like it's not
i mean those if there's a bunch of new
challengers they haven't really competed
they haven't really risen to the level
of an instagram or a twitter or facebook
as texas took over tick tock dude you're
right um i mean i even find myself just
being like i shouldn't like i should
post that in linkedin but it's like why
bother you know what i mean you get some
more views but who cares there's
diminishing returns so often on these
platforms and so one of the reasons why
we thought we need to build our own
website up
we can't just keep being a background
actor for someone else's website
we need our own it's an indication that
there's a monopoly and that's a big
problem
we've been tossing around ways to break
it up i don't think oligopoly it sure is
it's not just one company it's a it's a
cabal i don't think that's splitting
facebook into five different companies
at this point whatsapp instagram
facebook prime facebook messenger and
whatever else they got i don't think
that that's gonna work because zuck's
still gonna have all the code and he's
still going to control it all but i've
tossed around the idea of freeing
software code for any social media
network that gets over like a billion
users a day or 100 million users a day
or something i treat it as part of the
commons i disagree with you ian because
we had myspace it came and went all
because people said i had enough of this
myspace actually in 2007 i think i was
using it heavily with youtube and
blogging but then their site started to
grind to a halt for like 30 days you
couldn't use the site either because
mismanagement on their end it was before
aws before you could like had elastic uh
server space so i think they just
couldn't handle the load and then
facebook was there everyone went to
facebook look at look at parliament
started taking off and then the cabal
came and shot the government shut them
down alex jones was wildly popular and
the cabal came and and went after him
and nuked him from as a cascade they all
banned him on the same exact time so
what's the solution to that
oh man
well potential regulation look at alex
jones you know there's many some people
love him some people hate him but if you
look at the amount of views he has he
built his own platform he's doing pretty
well uh whatever yeah and the dude's
still and he's
still kicking butt so there's a lot of
different alternatives and we have to
remember that these social media
platforms are only as popular as we make
them so they're only prominent if we
make them prominent and at the end of
the day we have to understand that
they're fake they're they're creating a
perception of reality that's not true
it's a bunch of people controlling
people's minds by curating the algorithm
curating the timeline curating what they
see and manipulating them for their own
personal benefit as soon as people snap
out of this psychosis they'll understand
that well there's other alternatives out
there the internet was once great great
and free and amazing and incredible and
you could find exactly what you
subscribed to you can't do that anymore
so building up your own website what tim
did with tim cast i got my own website
with luke uncensored
is is essentially really incredibly
important alex jones has i think
ban.video and there's other people who
are d platform that have their own
platforms their own website their own
video services and they're kicking butt
and uh they have something that social
media doesn't have and that's
authenticity and people who actually do
want to listen to so one of the issues
you know
that started this conversation was that
cnn might not be as prominent anymore
youtube still puts them on the front
page
if you
open a brand new computer pull up
youtube you'll be like what reality is
this because it's crazy but uh cnn cbs
abc all of these establishment media
organizations that are wrong a
substantial amount of time are given
preferential access and they're all
thumbs down people despise this content
but it's there in front of your face so
it's quite amazing
when you you have on top of that you
also have a lot of progressive youtubers
who also get things
very very wrong on basic facts for
tribal partisan reasons i don't got a
problem if your opinion is trump sucks i
got a problem if you're like donald
trump did x and he didn't or you know
for example uh david pakman shout out he
said donald trump encouraged his uh
republicans not to vote which is just
flat out not true so but i get it look
we probably make mistakes as well i
can't blame him for you know having an
error but he doesn't he's
there's a lot of people
that
just recite what they see on mainstream
media hey i got another shout out for
david peckman when um i think it was it
was a chuck todd maybe meet the press
asked ted cruz if he thought ukraine
meddled in the election in 2016 and uh
ted cruz was like politico reported it
instead of the new york times and then
they start laughing on msnbc just
laughing and then david pakman runs that
clip and just agrees that without doing
any level of fact checking at all
for us uh i actually i think we have
like eight or nine reporters who
do the actual leg work and make the
phone calls i i make phone calls all the
time to try and fact check things one of
one of the best stories i think was mayo
gate where uh democrats ran a story
claiming that mayonnaise that a
restaurant was lying about the cost of
mayonnaise to make biden look bad when
reality they were telling the truth
mayonnaise was up like hundreds of
dollars per week for this restaurant so
when you have a mainstream media that
doesn't fact check and lies then you
have a progressive
and establishment youtube presence from
independent alternative creators who
also just regurgitate those lies
it's a very serious uphill battle and
then take into consideration that
youtube will prop up uh the young turks
for instance are on youtube tv and one
of my favorite segments they've done was
when we had a conversation on this show
about republicans being more attractive
than democrats and it was i should say
liberals versus conservatives there are
like five studies we went over that said
why are conservatives typically
considered more attractive than than
liberals are and i said because of
attractive privilege
people who grow up who are beautiful are
treated better and then say to
themselves if i could do it why can't
you well you were treated better you had
an easier life
the young turks ran a segment saying
that i was wrong i was ugly
posting pictures of me and insulting my
appearance and then ultimately conceded
well actually i was writing the studies
are true that goes up on youtube tv
that's what's propped up
so
we may have a big show joe may have a
big show
it's still
every day struggling against hundreds of
millions of views that cnn is given just
given
so if you go to like cnn's youtube
analytics you can see they get 100 to
200 million uh views per month oh i i
i mean my whole book apocalypse never
and also san francisco are basically
debunkings of what's been in the new
york times and on cnn around climate
change plastic waste extinctions drug
addiction homelessness housing the whole
thing
the question is what do you do about it
you know i mean i thought it was i mean
i was very disturbed that twitter can
remove a sitting president of the united
states from its platform and ban a
breaking news story about hunter biden
and then you get andy stone from
facebook coming out and saying we have d
ranked this story so it's harder to
share right and it was all true right so
what do you do about that i mean um i
come out of the energy i have a lot of
background energy we had a regulated
utility model in the enter in the
electricity sector that
we then experimented with not doing
starting in the early 2000s and
when you look at the performance of a
regulated utility model
monopoly utility versus the unregulated
model most of us in the space go the
regulated monopoly utility model worked
better
this is totally different obviously this
is not utilities or trains or or
electric utilities this is this is
information yeah you need to free the
software code i don't know if need is
the right word but if you could force
federate these companies so that you
could interoperate with them with news
force federate is a good idea and then
you would destroy their share value not
really because they make ad revenue no
they're basic their money is off of ads
which they'll still i mean facebook
killed um under obama they killed this
very modest legislation to regulate
content to have some government
oversight of content aimed at kids and
facebook quashed it they have lobbyists
for you know each party in each branch
of government
they squash that those guys are just
keeping a lid on anything i don't know
what the solution is but i thought it
was interesting after trump was taken
off of twitter after twitter took him
off trump took trump off that there were
a number of world leaders that were like
like what's the deal and i don't like if
you're running for political office and
you don't have a lot of money and you
want to be able to be able to have a
voice in there i don't think it's i
don't think it's good enough to be like
hey i'm not on facebook but go to
johnsmith.com
and check out my platform that's just
not going to cut it in today actually i
think i think ian may have just solved
everything forced federation so what
does that mean it means that
you can make your own server your own
website and then someone on facebook can
follow you on your site now facebook can
still ban you from their platform but
your platform never gets shut down
so you may lose access to facebook's
user base but you will keep your
platform and your followers can still
choose to follow you because it's your
website what concerns me is if the banks
start to like the swift payment system
wants to cancel you that's very
concerning we still have crypto but it's
not quite implemented yet um the and if
the isp wants to cut off your access to
the internet that's really concerning to
me too i know we have like starlink uh
coming out elon's thing but that's elon
owns that as far as i know so we maybe
utilitize that as well imagine if
twitter was by regulation we they were
these companies were opened up to the
federated network someone on gab could
then follow at tim cast you know or tim
at twitter.com timcast twitter.com and
then get my feed on that website and i
could be like well i still have the book
of my followers on twitter so i'll post
here but now anyone from any other site
can choose to just see my tweets is that
like net would that be like net
neutrality is that the same thing as no
platform neutrality no net neutrality is
about restricting access based on how
much you pay essentially like you can
the idea by net neutrality uh was that
you can't pay for faster access to
certain websites
so that whole thing was one of the most
ridiculous political battles that made
no sense and i think i'm pretty sure you
ask most people they're not going to
tell you what what it means
or
what side one of what under the model
under that model like let's say i want
to follow john smith candidate for mayor
of my hometown you could follow him
you're saying through twitter but you
couldn't see him have an argument with
other candidates on twitter
well you'd have to you'd have to you'd
have to mandate it then i mean the
government would have to require that no
no what do you mean well in other words
if twitter wants to say john smith can't
be on twitter even though he's a
candidate for mayor of
denver
because we don't like what he said
there's he john smith has no recourse
right now the problem is that twitter
dominates the political space the
political conversation and facebook and
youtube very much these this this cabal
in silicon valley does
and so they can they can pick winners
and losers facebook actually did
experiments on people where they showed
them certain content to see if they
would be happy or sad
sure enough showing sad content made
people sad well i think it was uh steve
huffman of reddit who said we could
swing an election if we really wanted to
oh sure they know they can and they
probably do but what if you just kept
the what if you just kept the candidate
off of all the platforms as far as i can
tell that's not violating any laws like
that like twitter google facebook can
keep john smith mayoral candidate of
denver off of all their platforms
this is this is the funny thing that's
like that's terrifying the funny thing
the right is just so bad at this it's
amazing
like when they're there are some uh
individuals running for office but
they're banned from twitter and so then
twitter says like you're not allowed to
have a presence it's like create a super
pac or you're not even a superb create a
pack a political action committee and
you'll call it like you know
john smith for congress pac
and it's not run by the candidate and
then you can absolutely advocate for him
if we were to say the candidate can't be
on the platform all that would happen is
democratic groups would set up pacs and
they would still get favorable treatment
so twitter would be like we're not going
to ban the pack for you know joe biden
but that donald trump won that's
offensive so you're gone
there's no real way to ban politics i
mean what if john smith is running for
president on a platform to regulate the
internet companies they'll destroy them
and then they were just like they were
like well he's not going to be on the
platform i mean what does that do to
american democracy oh yeah that's
exactly right it's definitely not
democratic they're fast they're
corporate fascists i mean the the
right now i struggle with this every all
these websites twitter facebook and
youtube have like a clause in their
terms that say we can ban anyone at any
time for no reason right so
i i don't want to legislate their terms
of service i find that fascist if we use
the government to decide what their
terms that's why i think we need the
software code freed so that other people
could spin up an identical copy of
twitter with access to all the twitter
info on their version of it and then
they could make their own terms of
service and then you'd start to have a
market of terms as opposed to a market
of who has the best code that's just too
communist for me though seizing the the
work and the intellectual property of a
company antitrust is kind of communist
well regulation isn't communism right
not everything is communism seizing the
means of production from a company to
distribute among the masses is pretty
common but i'm not gonna take their
servers but the code the code isn't
really the means of production i mean
the electric utility model is that
electric utilities were allowed to make
a certain amount of profits a year and
that was it and they were they had to
get permission to raise electrical rates
the dynamic that was created that the
electric utilities would constantly
trying to justify expensive activities
so they could you know make more money
for themselves but
you know now they're called natural
monopolies you know railroads electrical
utilities the power grid there are some
things where you kind of go
we can't figure out how breaking that up
is in anybody's interest and so we're
going to keep it together but regulate
it now i'm not sure what that looks like
federation the code is the means of
production but i don't want to i don't
want to steal it i want to copy the
means of production no it's very i think
very different i don't want to take it
away from them i want to copy it if if
you were on twitter and someone on gab
could follow your twitter account and
you could follow them on gab and then
twitter decides to ban you well you
chose to be on twitter but these other
platforms still exist
the the ultimately the idea i see for
how we solve this is
with what we're building with the uh the
fetiverse project you can set up your
own website have your own
social media feed and subscription
service and people can follow you
through any
fetaverse you know network that supports
it
no one can ban you because it's your
website
so then your followers will just be
following you i mean if you look at how
email works like newsletters i have a
huge list of email accounts and then i
can email them no one can ban you from
that ever because if they delete your
email account you can make an email
account like hey guys here's another
email i created a new example so no
matter what network i'm on i can
subscribe to tim at timcast from my
twitter from my youtube from facebook
from mindscap and then if twitter wants
to ban tim cast then i can still you
still have all your stuff yep that's
excellent and you can go on any other
platform and see it or you'll go right
to my website to see it no one will be
able to accept that the isps can
blockade your website that's what yep
yep it's not perfect there's uh there's
many links in that chain that can be
broken
well there you go under theorized is my
view we haven't really i think you're
right when you said that conservatives
haven't done a very good job thinking
about it i interviewed one guy uh who
did a piece for harvard business review
on this proposing a sort of regulated
utility model but
it's complicated it's much more simple
to do this with an electric utility or a
railroad than it is with information
well also the lobbies that they have are
also very big very powerful they have a
lot of influence they buy it they work
hand in hand i think the government
created this problem and
i think the problems that are created by
big tech social media directly help the
government and many different guys well
think about it like the funny thing is
when they were seeking to regulate the
uh
like you know when they were like
regulating the railroad industry or the
electric utility industry the railroad
electric utility industry didn't also
control the newspapers exactly that's
what we're talking about here and so you
how do you even have a debate about this
zuckerberg is the real president maybe
you could mesh network all the server
space so like everyone would have a
server in their house and so all my
website would be on my server and on
your server and on your server so if one
of us goes down because verizon wants to
cut us off or if so there's no real web
hoster either because the web host can
knock your
this is like a revenge of the nerds 1984
come together
and this is the reality that we're
living in where unelected shadowy
secretive nerds are literally calling
the shots creating culture dominating
and controlling people's minds in so
many different ways and so many
different aspects and there's no way to
even have any accountability here
here's a story that i that i love and
maybe you guys heard me talk about it
before
uh michael did you know that um
let me ask you a question do you have a
facebook profile i do do you know is
someone in your family have have they
not signed up for facebook not a single
one everybody has they all the facebook
do you know anyone who hasn't signed up
for facebook
i do not really everyone you know well i
mean i haven't asked them all what if i
told you that um regardless of whether
or not you sign up you do have a
facebook profile
that would
both blow my mind and not be surprising
at the same time here's how it works
so uh do you have facebook messenger yes
and when you sign in it says sync your
contacts with your phone there you go
did you do that yeah so here's what
happens they're called shadow profiles
so you have stored in your phone a
number that probably says mom i don't
know maybe the kind of guy calls her
mother i don't know but they can see
that word and the phone number because i
don't think you're going to put your mom
as like janet i don't know your mom's
name i actually do that oh you do you
put your mom's full name i put my mom's
actual name yeah so uh that's either way
it still works but here's what happens
you'll sync your account your contacts
let's say your mom never signed up
they now see facebook sees a list of
phone numbers and they see you know 555
1234 and janiece
they then see you have any siblings yes
all right so sibling a signs up but they
do say mom now they know janiece is
actually the mother of john right john
is the brother of michael now your mom
has a profile that lists her kids lists
her phone number they can collect little
bits of information from every facebook
profile to build what's called a shadow
profile now they know who your mom is
where she lives how old she is they know
what she's talking about and yes the
best part is they know when you poop
facebook system has so much information
on you they can actually predict when
you will go to the bathroom they can
actually i don't if you've ever seen the
ads but i remember i was on messenger
and an ad popped up in messenger about
like food network or something
as i was talking to somebody about
something like about to about to like i
didn't actually say anything and we were
talking about it there's people have all
these stories all day and night where
it's like
i remember i went to walmart
and they had a big thing of tvs in the
middle of the aisle they were on sale
when i got home and went on my computer
there was an ad for the exact photo of
the stack of tvs at the walmart and i
went
what the like are they spying on me are
they listening everybody thinks they're
listening that's not it
they have all of these data points which
allow them to predict your behaviors
they knew where i lived
they knew the stuff i'd been talking
about they easily said this guy needs a
tv
or this this is the kind of guy like we
didn't actually but actually no we did
buy a tv that's yeah and so they
advertised this stack of tvs from the
exact walmart to us
and and yet they still won't tell me
when my favorite bands are coming to
town i know i mean after like a decade
of that we still don't know when my
favorite bands are coming well is the
band paying them money probably not
exactly unfortunately so they will tell
you you know um
they'll give you recommended restaurants
so it's really amazing when they have
location data and map data and they can
see where you work the the proximity to
what restaurants that exist they can
tell if you're fit they can tell many
steps you take and then they say this is
a guy who likes to walk the computer
just calculates it so he's gonna he he
could choose any one of these
restaurants now let's say you are
sedentary lazy never move they would
probably be like we predict he's gonna
go next door for a burger and because
it's the easiest path there's a million
one different reasons you know they know
everything about you they know your
address they know your location they
know where the closest murder burger is
right next to you they know what you buy
i mean everything's interconnected and
they sell your data like entrepreneurial
drug dealers and they sell it to the
creepiest sleaziest nastiest disgusting
entities out there that are willing to
do anything for a buck and they do
that's another idea because the best
part is um
i don't know which company it was
but they the companies that take your
dna and then they'll send it back like a
medical report or
history and then they were like we'll
never sell your data but then the
company got bought
right people should get paid for their
data perhaps something that a good
really smart friend of mine from naval
intelligence keeps telling me is that we
should at least get a large percentage
of our data when facebook makes sells it
they're making a lot of money off that
stuff
let's uh let's let's let's uh at least
get uh one conversation going about
what's going on in san francisco because
we have this story
uh from sfgate car break-ins in san
francisco are rampant will a 100 000
reward help you know what i love about
this let me let me read they say on
tuesday morning mayor london breed
announced a new privately funded reward
of up to a hundred thousand dollars
leading to the arrest and conviction of
individuals involved in organized crime
rings which the mayor's office says
fuels automobile burglaries the reward
is funded by private by private donors
in the hospitality and tourism industry
wow
press release the mayor's office did not
immediately return a request for more
information about these private donors
so um
san francisco has become this nightmare
dystopia of failed policy oligarchs
funding
uh reward bounties i have to i have to
imagine the hundred thousand dollars
could just go to like i don't know
hiring police
yeah i mean this is this is a disturbing
trend it's also rise of private security
in san francisco it's been very
prominent
we're in a huge crisis of morale with
the police that's been there ever since
last summer
and it's resulting in greater homicides
and greater crime overall and
you know one of the interesting
questions i had when i was working on
san francisco was
because so much of what is justified in
san francisco in terms of open air drug
use public defecation public camping
these things are defended as ways of not
blaming the victim
you know helping the victim so one
question is why would then do
progressive support policies that end up
creating so many more victims
and the answer it turns out is that
progressives are really focused on
saving the victims of the system
they're not so this is why you know 30
times more african-americans are killed
by civilians than by police officers so
why the disproportionate attention on
police killings
because those are killings by people
that are perceived as the system so
progressive you know the word
progressive really was a way to both
change move away from the word liberal
which was demonized in the late 1980s
it was also though a way to kind of
unite both the radical left and more
moderate liberals
but one of the things that it inherited
is this idea that really the only you
know that the system itself is evil and
corrupt and that we should only care and
make a big deal out of the victims of
that system and so you just see all
these efforts to basically do anything
other than do what needs to be done
which is restore confidence in our in
the institutions of civilization in the
institutions of the so-called system you
i guess uh
i don't know if well i'll just ask you
used to be i guess a lefty leftist or
liberal how would you describe yourself
yeah i would have described myself as
radical left uh certainly in the 90s um
i worked on now you're not you're far
right of course
i'm here aren't i yeah
i
yeah i worked on um
uh environmental causes climate change i
worked on you know criminal justice
issues in the 1990s there's some people
in the comments section saying that you
are connected to soros george soros
yeah i worked for george soros's uh
funded organizations but also his
foundation itself the open society
institute
how is that what was it impactful for
your kind of political ideology can you
speak to that a little bit because i'm
getting a lot of comments about that in
the comment section
yeah so
well so you know we have to remember you
know you're coming out in the 1980s and
1990s were coming out of a big war on
drugs and a widely held view that we had
overreacted to things like crack and
that what we should have been doing is
drug treatment is mandating rehab rather
than sending guys off to the prisons for
decades and that's still mostly of you i
hold there was also other things going
on there was liberalization of opioid
pharmaceuticals because it was viewed as
we were under treating pain and then we
were also promoting the
decriminalization of marijuana which we
viewed as a relatively benign
drug particularly in comparison to
alcohol and cigarettes
and then also we were advocating for
providing clean needles to addicts
because of a way to stop hiv aids
transmissions
when i got out of that work around the
year 2000 my understanding was that we
were seeking to make drug rehabilitation
including work including compliant you
know
taking your psychiatric meds doing what
you need to do to live a healthy life my
understanding was that we were going to
continue to mandate those things as an
alternative to prison what ended up
happening
not in a single law but in a set of laws
and ballot initiatives is that we
basically just said
no you can we've decriminalized stealing
950 worth of items from walgreens we've
decriminalized three grams of hard drugs
that was in the same ballot initiative i
voted for it 62 percent of californians
voted for it prop 47 in the year 2014
but you put those two things together
decriminalizing three grams of fentanyl
and meth and stealing 950
worth of items and you get
yes organized crime but crimes that are
being committed to feed people's
addictions you know one of the things
that really bugged me and i mentioned
this the other day but i talk about a
lot i hear it all the time from the
progressives there are more empty houses
than homeless people having actually
worked with
homeless
shelters more than one
uh you learn a lot about why people are
homeless and it's not this fancy this
fantasy idea of people being like pardon
me sir i'm desperate for a place to live
it's actually people who are like get
away from me i want to be homeless and
they're drinking and you try and you try
and be nice respectful you try to help
people but a lot of them you know
outside of mental illness there are
people who are literally like don't come
near me or else yeah yeah you got it i
mean basically what happens is
in the 1980s
you see multiple things going on but
basically you have a crack epidemic
which is really crack and alcohol those
are the two drugs that would get paired
a lot
resulting in homelessness meaning that
people would be
they would quit their jobs and dedicate
their day hours to their addictions they
would then disaffiliate this is the
academic word disaffiliation they would
basically become alienated from friends
and family who they had stolen from or
borrowed money from and finally friends
and family are like you gotta leave
they're kicking you out so you basically
that is how people became
homeless
there was also then
de-institutionalization of our
psychiatric hospitals a lot of those
folks were dumped on the streets
so that was what was going on in the 80s
the radical left
really working with liberals um
basically said these people the problem
with these folks is that they don't have
housing and there was always a move for
socialized housing and and and basically
free public housing
so they literally invented this
propaganda word there's no other way to
say it homelessness itself is a
propaganda word designed to trick your
brain
into putting people with totally
different problems in the same category
including people with schizophrenia
people with a heroin problem and the
proverbial mother escaping an abusive
husband the mother escaping the abusive
husband who doesn't have a drug drug or
alcohol problem and is not mentally ill
we do a great job of helping that woman
there's that's not a problem okay
the the person with schizophrenia and
the person with with an addiction those
folks on the street that's a huge
problem not just both for them it's
immoral the way we treat them but also
it's it degrades the fabric of a city do
you think do you think living in san
francisco led to kind of a political
transition for you and are there any
kind of policies you advocated for
under the kind of soros uh that were the
influence that you kind of regret now
great question so i mean one thing is
there's certain there's certainly
i have become more conservative around
drugs and alcohol um i still support the
decriminalization of marijuana but i
would like to see it more heavily
regulated i still support alcohol being
legal but i
i think amount i actually come to see
things like not being able to buy at the
grocery store not gonna buy on sunday
things that restrict
uh uh consumption i think is is good um
you know psychedelics i worry that we're
just just diving headlong into basically
decriminalizing psychedelics without any
thought about what the implications of
that are
you know i when in the 90s i still
remember very vividly being in
progressive non-profits it was global
exchange in san francisco reinforced
action network we all hung out together
and the homeless advocates struck me as
it just struck me as bizarre because all
i always knew just because i was pretty
street savvy even in my 20s because i
had done a fair amount of just traveling
and i talked to people
i just knew that these folks were
addicts and that they were had mental
illness and so this sort of the kind of
emotional defense of the right of these
people to sleep on the sidewalks i
always sort of viewed as bizarre like it
never made any sense to me still to this
day you'll see progressives
high profile youtubers posting things
like that's proof of the of the do you
know the dysfunctional nature of
capitalism and unlike someone saying
they don't want to be in a building is
not anything to do with capitalism at
all well it's sad too i mean they're
these are often what they're they're
defending the right of psychotic people
in psychotic states whether from
underlying schizophrenia or from heavy
meth use it always manifests the same
way
defending you know we don't we don't
like grandma with dementia and
alzheimer's live on the street so why do
we do that with people in a psychotic
state well let's take their argument
where they say there are more empty
houses than homeless people do we just
take a you know 30 year old
schizophrenic man put him in a house and
say have a nice day what do you think
would happen to that person in that
house if you just put they have no food
they have how they can afford utilities
how are they going to maintain the
building
what's going to happen to it well we
know i mean we've actually been doing an
ongoing experiments on this question and
then we had a big one during covid
because we had to because they reduced
the shelter populations people in hotels
the hotel first of all a lot of people
died because there wasn't another
user with them to revive them with
narcan after they overdosed
it's multi-factorial obviously so
there's also we're also doing a fentanyl
epidemic which is um uh incredibly
deadly so first that happened i mean the
propaganda has been and this is the
propaganda coming from
the big foundations rockefeller but it
also comes from malcolm gladwell at the
new yorker and it also came from george
w bush in the in the in the early 2000s
which was just give people housing
that's the cure
the evidence was never there for any of
it um in fact it doesn't over harvard
just published a major study on this
over a 12-year period
those folks do not retain their housing
any better than anybody else does but it
doesn't do anything to address the
underlying causes of homelessness which
are mostly addiction untreated mental
illness there's a lot of political
commentators that directly point the
finger at individuals like george soros
when they got involved in local politics
appointing da's and implementing a lot
of these policies what's your kind of
train of thought with his involvement
with the the things that he called for
that he paid for that he kind of caused
in major cities yeah i mean so george
soros his orientation is around um i
would call him a left libertarian and
that is a that is the cat that is left
libertarian
would encompass kind of the anarchist
that the anarchist that took over
seattle for example which is something i
discussed in the book but it also
includes people like soros i i quote the
person who worked for source for a long
time somebody that i i knew pretty well
i've known for almost 25 years and he
said you know he goes george's view is
that people should if people want
something
they should have access to it you know
and so
it's a kind of that's a kind of
libertarian mentality you want heroin or
fentanyl well you should be able to buy
it like why should we restrict your
freedom so that's part of it but then
there's the the more
liberal or the more left part is also
this idea well those people are probably
victims too
so there's two separate conceptual
universes that are being married in this
so it kind of goes
you want access to fentanyl and you're a
victim and therefore we should give you
whatever you want not just the needles
but a place to sleep and we should give
you medical care but we shouldn't do
anything to persuade you not to use
fentanyl or meth much less like enforce
laws against you because that would be
immoral because you're a victim yeah a
lot of basic pictures a lot of the da's
in a lot of very important places are
directly backed by him he gives a lot of
money and this buys them a lot of
influence like in loudon county county a
county not far away from us where a big
story broke that some people literally
yeah some people are being censored a
few days ago the prosecutor tried to
give the father who was the victim in
this in this case prison sentence for
showing up at a school board meeting and
raising concerns about this and and this
prosecutor had 860 000 dollars given to
him by a solos pack his name is bhuta
benjari
and and he's literally implementing
policy on the local level in such a way
where it's extremely political extremely
divisive a lot of times very hardened
criminals get get off and a lot of
people for political crimes go to jail
for very hard sentences so that's why i
was kind of hinting and i kind of wanted
to talk to you about it because you seem
to have kind of experience in it but but
a lot of people are pointing to this as
some of the main reasons why there's
such urban decay happening all over the
united states and that's why i kind of
wanted their feedback
soros has a lot to answer for he's
supporting these people he's supporting
you know progressive das who have just
clearly gone too far into victimology
i think he's just deeply out of touch
he's very old at this point i don't
think he has
you know a lot of these guys are like
they don't you know i say this is the
edge of the problem and part of the
problem in california do you know i'll
describe i would describe what i'm
working on to people that i knew and
they'd go
yeah
well that's why i don't go downtown
and you're kind of like yeah but aren't
we like uh what about like the whole
thing about how we're a kind of a single
community in a single country or a
single city or have some whatever
happened to like brotherly love or you
know you are your brother's keeper i
mean that's all gone it's kind of like
or i once after the recall failed
against the current governor i
tweeted out something that was like this
is a problem because we've got this
human rights
crisis on the streets
and somebody responded by putting a
picture of them in their just kind of
douchey little bicycle shorts on a
bicycle like taking a selfie of them
with the golden gate bridge in the
background being like but look at how
beautiful it is and i was like well yeah
my house is nice too but like
712 people died unnecessarily last year
on the streets of san francisco out of
your supposed compassion so pull your
head out of your ass and let's do
something about this as opposed to just
being like i don't go downtown when i
went to sweden several years ago you
know donald trump goes on tv says last
night in sweden and then created this
huge thing so i was like i'll go there
we went to a place called rinkaby
initially everything was like fine we
went to rosengard and they were like
it's dangerous but it was fun
in ring could be in the middle of the
day at lunch time it was crowded we
actually started getting threats people
were yelling at us and the police told
us we should probably leave the cop said
to me look if if these people start
throwing stones like we can't protect
you and then i was like okay so we'll go
because we were we had cameras and so
they were yelling stuff fast like
express in they thought we were a news
outlet from sweden
because we had a small camera one of the
cameras we use here actually the same
kind
and so one of these other journalists
said oh he's exaggerating it's not
dangerous i'll prove it i'll go there
and so this woman shows up there
goes does not go into the center
shopping area of rinkaby where where we
were stands outside the arches in the
middle of the night wearing a full coat
that covered her hands you couldn't see
the color of her skin you couldn't see
anything about her with her back to the
entrance and said see look i'm here in
the middle of the night and and it's
just that's that's how the media
manipulates and plays these dirty games
to say there's no problem here nothing
to see here the reality was yes a small
blonde woman at two in the morning when
no one's around wearing a coat covering
every inch of her body and not actually
going in will make a lot of people think
there's no problem because people assume
the middle of the night's when it's
dangerous no the middle of the day is
when it was dangerous when there was a
hundred plus people there and they
didn't like the the press and they took
issue with people based on their skin
color
so they'll they'll they'll sleep under
the rug using assumptions tropes and
manipulation oh yeah i mean we've seen
that uh there's basically been an effort
to deny that crime has been increasing
in california over the last 10 or 20
years
we've seen a huge decline in arrests
uh per reports for shoplifting and so
one of the things they'll say is we'll
say well we were seeing you know fewer
arrests well that doesn't mean there's
less crime we do i got one more question
for you on this subject um real quick
have murders in san francisco gone up or
down they've gone up over the last two
years certainly since the george floyd
protests do you want to know why that's
so substantial
murder rates around the world have been
going down for one reason and do you
know what it is if you had to guess why
would murder rates be going down
for for the past uh i believe it's about
the past 13 or so years
until now well i mean in the book i
describe um
a variety of factors but i mean the two
big ones i looked at were better
policing and rising legitimacy
the answer is actually cell phones
the crimes are still being committed but
people have the ability to call ems
within seconds as opposed to before the
era of the ubiquitous smartphone
people would say would see an emergency
and then run to find a phone which
dramatically increased response time so
i actually learned this when i was in
sweden
they were what they were saying was the
progressives were trying to say oh no
look you know like even though crime is
going up it's not that much except when
you look at homicide rates in other
countries they were all in a downward
trend
and what we ended up discovering was
since cell phones became something
everyone had when it when a lethal crime
was committed or which which a crime
that could be potentially lethal people
immediately called the police
the ambulance got there within minutes
this decreases the amount of murders
but increases the amount of attempted
murders or aggravated crimes
so the united states we saw we've seen
murders going down in a lot of ways for
places where murders are going up that's
in spite of the fact that people now
have the opportunity to call emergency
services which is exacerbated by the
fact when you defund the police and now
calling gets you nothing
so now we start seeing it go back up
yeah i mean certainly i think there's
it's a it's a it's a complicated um area
there's um i tend to side with
two basic strands of research one
showing that declining belief in the
legitimacy of the government and the
system
corresponds with increasing hor
increasing homicides this is all based
on this work from a book called american
homicide by randolph roth but then i
also um you know the growing consensus
among a lot of criminologists is that
the rise in homicides after ferguson in
2015
and then after the george floyd uh
killing and the black lives matter
protest last summer
was due to basically what we call the
ferguson effect which is the
emboldenment of criminals out of
declining legitimacy but also the
pulling back of police from the kind of
street you know walking the streets
interacting with with the folks
including the folks that are more likely
to come at home we gotta we gotta go to
super what's the declining legitimacy we
gotta go to super chat because we're way
way can we define we could talk about
this in the after segment definitely so
if you haven't already smash that like
button and we we definitely went a
little late so uh and we have a hard
stop so we're gonna try and read as many
super chats as we can
all right matthew hammond says has he
seen the nuclear battery technology that
never needs to be charged in last 20 000
years
yeah that doesn't exist
[Laughter]
it does i mean there was a news report
about it but i think it's grossly
greatly exaggerated there's a lot of
there's a lot of reports for designs and
these aren't even design is a bit of a
strong word for it um these are more
like ideas these are these are
spitballing
i mean the history of nuclear is a
history of um a lot of enthusiasts a lot
of technical enthusiasts
and very few successful real world
innovations mostly we've succeeded
with nuclear it's similar to jet planes
you know i think one day we will have
hydrogen-fueled jet planes that will get
us from la to australia in an hour
that's that day is a long ways off and
until then we should stick with the
kerosene power jet planes that we have
and or basically my view of nuclear
that's what honestly they would be yeah
that's what they would be
so but i mean nuclear is just extremely
it's obviously super complex uh
technology it's also heavily regulated
uh both for national security and for
radiological reasons all right john r
says nice shelf why it was john r the
other day who said you should put up a
shelf
so we have michael's books uh san
francisco and apocalypse never and it
was actually like five minutes before
the show they're like can andy put up
the shelf real quick and then he drilled
the shelf in because we were trying to
like put the books up and we were like
john had a good idea yeah and so we
rolled we we went with it
all right let's see what we got
let's try and find some good questions
all right let's see we got some let's go
brandon's all right let's go brandon
okay
king tesseract says this one's to
michael i hear you advocating for
nuclear all the time why haven't you
told people about thorium and lftr
reactors they seem pretty awesome
especially since the u.s it's a lot of
thorium
yeah i mean this is the same kind of
question around the nuclear battery or
about fusion so
we originally had experimented with a
number of different designs what is
often called thorium is basically a new
uh
fuel coolant combination
you don't need thorium for it thorium is
an alternative to uranium but it doesn't
offer many of the benefits that people
have said it would you can still
make weapons-grade materials out of
these
technologies
you know we had the idea was that if
it's already melted if the fuel cooling
combination's already melted then you
won't have a meltdown and so it would
add some safety benefits but the problem
is is that that particular
fuel coolant combination the coolants
are usually made out of chemicals either
fluoride or beryllium or lithium or some
combination of them
the problem is is that they create
different problems for the metals
and also for the process of creating
them in the first place you have to have
a chemical combination and separation
system
so it's just proven to be
really expensive and difficult and so
that's why they don't exist i've been
focused on trying to keep the nuclear
reactors that we have that are running
continue to be running and not shut down
early most of them can run for 80 or 100
years or more
are these the ones that use corium is
the in the reactor in the core the thing
they use uranium and then if it melts
down it's considered is that corium is
that what these rods these well i mean
if it melts down it turns into a big
mess you know but i thought about if
could you pour a superconductor into the
mess and allow it to cool over time like
gold
i am not i do not have an answer to that
question but i can say that when every
time we've had the mess whether the big
ones like in chernobyl or fukushima it's
just been a huge headache to deal with i
mean that's why we're if there were some
simple technical fix to it then
we would have it the trouble is getting
in there once it's melted that's the all
the drones shut down so they've had a
hard time getting in but i wonder if you
could get a superconductor in the
aquarium and allow it to cool down
yeah there's a lot of research on it i
mean um
and that's obviously the desire for some
radically different technology my view
is that these accidents are not unusual
for a new technology that new
technologies should we should expect
some amount of accidents the ones that
we had were not the big public health
disasters that people think that they
were
you know best estimates are somewhere
around 200 people total will have died
from chernobyl after an 80-year period
that's nothing compared to the 6 million
lives we think are shortened every year
from air pollution that much of the fear
and panic around nuclear stems from
anxiety around the bomb
which remains the only real
technological way to create an
apocalyptic scenario or the destruction
of civilization that we have other than
asteroids or super volcanoes
so my view is that and then it was also
politicized
and the opposition to nuclear came from
a lot of different areas but my view is
that
i tend to be technologically more
conservative because every time they
have tried to significantly change the
ways in which nuclear reactors operate
the costs have gone up significantly
because it's just the workers the work
of building a nuclear plant is mostly
pouring cement and rebar and welding
pipes
but that work is all req the demands are
that that work be done at a level that's
much higher than for natural gas or coal
plants
and so my concern is just that when we
start radically changing the technology
you start getting big cost overruns and
we want to keep the nuclear cheap i once
uh read a story about a scuba diver i
think it was who got sucked into an
intake pipe at a nuclear power plant and
was fine because uh the the water blocks
radiation uh-huh so it was just like
warm water that's enough maybe it's not
true though i was like it was one of
those books
or something like that all right let's
read a little bit more ao shooter says
please shout out stop button barcade bar
plus arcade equals awesome hey very very
cool
all right um many people are saying ian
the hippie authoritarian and they're
saying things like that
all right let's see
zach darce
says website member here thank god luke
is back ian clearly doesn't understand
rights at all and always conflates the
issue into nonsense your human rights to
not be aggressed upon is inherent and
immutable authoritarian
no luke said that it was this human
right to go shopping
no that's not what i said don't you dare
go to a restaurant defunk my message and
i said government intervening in your
life is is not good probably maybe this
will turn forward
i'll go listen to it later cold water
says i also live in the sf bay area and
my daughter and i were yelled at on a
nature trail we were both masked but we
were going the wrong way to reduce
transmission my response call the police
well if you're in australia you get
arrested for being on a nature walk and
not having a mask there's been tons of
videos tons of incidences of people
getting brutalized by thugs with badges
for simply walking in nature by
themselves with their family members
without a mask
in the uk they sent helicopters hunting
people down in the middle of nature by
themselves to go after them and arrest
them
oh weird
bones says i just sent his 20 super chat
and youtube removed my comment i didn't
even violate tos i just happened to
mention the book of revelation huh
interesting
conspiracy
kev says ian you're wrong australia did
violate basic human rights the daily
wired did a piece four newborn babies
die after australian covet 19
restrictions prevent travel look it up
interesting that sucks
all right let's see what we got
ish that offends people podcast says
idaho mom here we took my six-year-old
to haki tonight after two years of being
robbed of it kid was told he couldn't
skate without mask mandated to be on ice
for children who rarely die from the vid
they're muzzling kids like animals this
is insanity and abuse won't go back yeah
in colorado springs a teacher masked
sixth graders with tape over their face
because she said that the kids weren't
wearing the masks properly
so there's a lot of insanity out there
we do have a a bit of a update as well
steambub says you can threaten someone
in the u.s it's only illegal if you
intend to follow through which is an
interesting line but you can also you
can also threaten people in response to
things or as statements of a logical
follow-through in that if you do x i
will
do x to you yeah i'm not sure that how
you would determine an intent in that
way i think right we're looking at
speech there well the interesting thing
is it's also typically discretion of the
cop and most threats will never be
prosecuted
or you know yeah uh unless it's against
like a public official
then you're in the territory of like yo
we don't yeah and you're in stock you're
not allowed to stalk people
you know i mean it's it's definitely it
gets into gray areas well well hold on
um
it's it's depending on the the legal
line of what stalking is so when you're
like outside their house on their
property looking through the window
calling them repeatedly
so if but if you were watching someone
leave and you followed them
they could file like a civil action and
say you know stop following me or
something but you're never gonna get
arrested for that so can't is more so uh
it's frowned upon yeah you're right in a
sense you have to be violating other
laws you can get a protective order
you know
all right bad b says we are living in a
herbert marcuse world right now if you
check him on ever check him out
everything going on right now will make
sense yep well there you go true
bruno branowski says i'm driving to the
event from chicago if anyone wants a
ride i'll give them my plus one ticket
my info is on my github resume and that
is bruno bronoski wow driving from
chicago that's fun we're going to it's
going to be in harpers ferry we're doing
this event on saturday with ryan
and danny yeah it's going to be a whole
lot of fun
joe says corporate fascism like zillow
buying up homes and reselling them for
100k more one week later not flipping
them just reselling to price us out
yikes wow
that's crazy
gideon says hey team i live in new
zealand the government is bringing out
the digital passports digital ids
unvaccinated will be restricted to
essential services only keep up the good
work yep
here we go it's like black mirror you're
gonna have your social credit score have
you seen the chinese social credit score
stuff yeah that's insane the world
economic forum literally released videos
talking about how great it is to have a
domestic passport system that's going to
be checked everywhere with your health
and it's going to control you with every
aspect of your existence uh the video is
creepy as hell mike bloomberg unity says
tax the poor they're too stupid to buy
their own stuff so we got to do it for
them well that's the life everyone's
hoping to live your pursuit of happiness
based on what michael bloomberg has
decided is best for you
all right let's see
carson lieberger says i can vouch for
tim here on the facebook profile thing
i've had a shadow account for over five
years and i've never made an account
learned about it learn about the account
from friends well the shadow profiles
aren't public and there was a glitch
that happened one day where apparently
facebook made them publicly visible to
people and everyone's like what is this
what is this weird account with my
information on it and that's basically
how people discovered
shadow profiles are a real thing shady
all right and philip says more follow-up
on being paid for our personal data like
realties costly and administratively
cumbersome make facebook disclose each
time they sell share trade our data
the issue is
your data is worthless
however the data of a million people in
one area is worth full
so i've heard people say we got to get
paid for our data facebook should be
paying us for our data and i'm like oh
yeah the
.00001 cent that you would get from the
information they have on you combine it
all and when you have a pool of a
million people well they can sell that
for not even that much but it's
incentive to go with facebook for
advertising so they do make money off it
but i guess the bigger issue is people
assume that facebook takes your data and
then sells it to big companies for
experiments or stuff like that and they
they've done similar they've done things
like that that's partly what the
cambridge analytica thing was all about
but reginald enterprises says facebook
does give you money for your data they
do so by offering a free service that
costs them money
well interesting that's different though
yeah when something's free you're the
product that's what they say yep
all right let's see we got here we've
got a bunch of new super chats coming in
jeffrey mccorman says his name was david
dorn
someone sent us a picture of david dorn
we have it hanging in the green room
that's right
jonathan galterini says i gave a speech
on net neutrality for law school who has
the power to control access the
government or your service provider can
at t slow the speed of sites they do not
like themselves can the government force
them do the same one must have the power
well why why should one must have the
power
shouldn't
people have equal access to the internet
i would think so
i guess the issue is the argument
against uh net neutrality was
if i got the money i should be able to
buy better access right i should be able
to get faster access to att at t should
be able to pay the provider and say make
it easier to get to our website but if
you do that it's scary because then all
of a sudden well if you're conservative
you're not gonna be able to go to
infowars it'll be really difficult to
load you know sites like that and the
things you want to you want to read
all right let's see
steve otten says you should look into
getting ben davidson as a guest from
suspicious observers the signs he
presents as rock solid and he needs to
be heard interesting we'll look it up
toby walker says ian is right we should
crowdsource to buy out these platforms
and open the code the societal impact of
social media is more than tech moguls
can manage open algorithms are the only
way we can ever guarantee a fair system
or no algorithms just get rid of my
right
you follow the people you want to follow
and if you follow a million people your
feed will just be an endless stream of
contents just cycling through and that's
what you want that's what you get i
think that guy's uh your suggestion to
crowd sources i think crowdsourcing is
underutilized right now because if we
can pull a hundred thousand people
together to throw ten bucks at something
that's a million we could buy a huge
piece of land and then turn it into a
public park or something we do the same
thing with
ultimately companies
all right austin waiters
walters says the issue isn't where they
post it's how you follow make an rss
feed in the browser pull a person's post
from the various sites then make a news
feed who you follow is stored in a
browser extension
interesting interesting we could uh you
know yeah
all right let's see dh says forced
federation is the true solution to big
tech and antitrust is the way it needs
to be enforced
i it's i i definitely think forced
federation is a good idea for those that
weren't like
don't understand or you know just to re
re um contextualize
this would mean that twitter has to
allow you to follow gab accounts so you
could be on twitter you could follow
someone gab so twitter's like
oh but we'll ban the gab network it's
like okay well then as long as you're
hosting your own
platform
people on twitter can follow you twitter
can ban your website from their website
but your account would still exist you'd
still keep your subscribers and all that
good stuff and maybe you can't ban a
network maybe that's something that
could be worked on right now you can ban
a user but banning a network that's uh i
think banning network is totally fine if
i'm if timcats.com says we don't want
these posts appearing on our on our site
then we just say this one doesn't come
but then facebook could ban every
network that's not facebook twitter and
then people are going to be like i can't
follow people i want to follow it would
just not be federated it would be like a
bypassing the federation if they ban
everything other than their own network
so i see what you're saying
it would have to be for like specific
things
you know
i guess it's tough this is a good
conversation yeah they'd still try and
find a way to ban external networks
so yeah maybe you can't
but then
yeah that's interesting because then
facebook's like we don't want this stuff
appearing on our site it's like don't
worry it's not it's appearing on their
site
there and then facebook would have to
like file a complaint maybe i don't know
man it's it's tough i do think
censorship is important
um people people uh we we usually have
like a black and white approach but you
know enough talks about censoring
criminal content very disgusting images
yeah we want sensors to be like we're
not going to show that that involves
children no dice that can't be there
and so
the problem is when the censorship is
political and used to weaponize the
system for one you know one group's
political gain or something like that
that's that's the challenge
yeah it's really a parent's job to
censor what their kids see but man in
this world that's a whole other
conversation
ball game
justin meyer says i've been told that
unvaccinated delta employees have a 200
surcharge for healthcare have you guys
heard about this yeah yeah that's delta
right uh it's weird because i i don't
know we have to fact check that but
delta was i think the only airline that
wasn't implementing mandates uh from
what i heard one of them was doing 200
fees yeah i'm pretty sure delta does
have some mandates just not not in the
traditional sense yeah so a lot of
people are still criticizing them
all right stephen taylor says much love
and update from utah elk hunt successful
filled both my spike and cow tag
winter's meet secured ooh very nice nice
all right alex
maggiore
from someone who was once homeless trust
me if you don't want to be homeless you
don't have to be there are too many
government programs that will put you
back on your feet
and a lot of these homeless shelters
often empty
yeah this is a lot of what else a lot of
these you left it left us understand
when they're like why aren't we putting
homeless people in homes why are
homeless shelters empty and there are
many of them that or at the very least
why are they not at capacity
there are many shelters that i've
personally experienced that were like
straight empty and they would go out and
they would be like sir please like we
have a space for you and they'd be like
get away from me i'm not going to
whatever it is you're going to you're
going to you're doing they might come in
take a shower and leave sometimes
they'll shut up knock on the door like
i'm gonna come and take a shower and
then they would leave they wouldn't be
there it depends i mean part of the
reason one of the reasons that people
don't like standing shelters is because
you can't use drugs in the shelter
that's right
and they and they sometimes will make
you do certain things get clean change
your clothes yeah but the point you know
like new york had at least before the
before the pandemic they'd been
sheltering you know 99 of the homeless
but yeah you have to you have to decide
that you're not going to allow public
camping and then you have to build one
of the things i discovered that was
striking was that it had been homeless
advocates themselves who had opposed
building sufficient shelter space in
california out of the belief that
everybody deserved housing
and that the shelters just weren't good
enough for people and you gotta and
people need to understand uh there's a
lot of homeless people who go to
california specifically because it's
really nice weather and you can sleep
outside and
there's not gonna be a solution and use
dr and use you can have three grams of
hard drugs and still 950 for the goods
it's really a recipe for disaster well i
remember when i was living in seattle
there were a bunch of homeless kids like
late teens
that hung out near uw university of
washington and they would they would
ride the freight rails to make it there
they wanted to be homeless there was no
changing their minds this was their life
their passion their fun their community
and
just
that's it there's something i mean
there's a there's a part of there's a
wildness to it there's a part of it
that's very romantic
and i don't object to it um but i don't
think you have a right to sleep wherever
you want that's the difference is that
like i'm sort of and i have the same way
about drugs which is that if you want to
kill yourself
in the privacy of your own apartment i
don't think that we should dedicate
public resources to chasing you down but
you don't get to overdose and use hard
drugs in public because that's a
violation of public space my friend was
working with homeless and i believe she
told me that at some point the san
francisco city was going through with
fire hoses at 4am and just hosing all
the homeless people off the side of the
road did you ever hear anything about
that no i never i they i they use the
language that's used it's not great
language i don't use it myself as the
idea of sweeps
but i think the way you have to think
about it is that these are open drug
scenes meaning that these are places
where there's an open air drug market
and users who are living there
we only know one way to close open air
drug scenes it's the same way the
europeans have done it which is that you
use a combination of police and social
services you require people to be in
shelter so it's shelter first treatment
first housing is earned
but no i that would be grossly cruel and
i never came across that and that sounds
like the kind of rhetoric that honestly
the radical left might use i almost feel
like i saw video of it i i gotta confirm
i would be shocked if they were spraying
uh cold water on people yeah um
i'm not saying it maybe maybe it
happened but if it did that is
absolutely not okay and that could not
have been sustained but they'll sweep
like just the cops will go in and grab
people and be like you gotta go we're
talking on a bus like what are they
doing like usually you give you usually
give several days of warning that you
have to stop being there um social
services are offered
most people take the offer or they leave
and go somewhere else and then there's a
few hardcore people that won't leave and
sure then they get arrested i mean you
don't have a right to sleep wherever you
want we have designated camping areas
and if you don't want to sleep there
then my view is that we should have
sufficient shelter space for you but you
don't it's not it's not a thing where
you just get to sleep you know in the
playground and use heroin wherever you
want and defecate wherever you want
that's not compatible with civilization
agreed all right danny douglas says
trying to get my ticket i'm in the era
temporarily before getting shipped out
to guam this is my only chance to come
and meet you guys before 2024.
so um
man it's tough because
you know we chose a smaller venue with a
couple hundred capacity and the tickets
sold out instantly we're doing an
auction now and the goal is to do it you
know um
probably we have one going right now
for so if you're a member at 10ks.com
you can go in and there people are
bidding at last i checked i think it's
like 175 dollars was the bid and we did
this because we're just trying to do
like
some people
happen to see you know they're able to
be on the website they see the post
they're able to get the ticket because
tickets were free for members of 25 or
more
some people are too busy and didn't have
the opportunity to so they have the
opportunity to just buy like a use use
auction you know purchase a ticket but
we're gonna do an auction we have an
auction today tomorrow and we're i think
we're gonna do it uh tuesday wednesday
thursday friday we'll probably do two
separate auctions on friday because we
have a total of 10 tickets that you can
just bid for and we're going to be
ending the auctions randomly we're going
to let them stay up for a little while
um but we're going to end them randomly
because we don't want people to be
avoiding bidding we want we want you to
just be like here's my bid i want to
come and then we'll ultimately just be
like we're going to cut it off at like
10 p.m or something so
we're trying to find a way to do it as
fair as possible it's very difficult
typically when you do auctions people
say oh wait to the last five seconds and
then bid whatever the next bit is and so
then everyone's got to sit there and
wait and it's really annoying so
oh man we're trying to figure it out to
make it the best possible we can and the
fairest we can but it's certainly not
that easy
all right let's just do uh we'll do one
more funny one
garhent says tim this is my third time
being broadcasted for this point could
you please get one of ian's
personalities to take the political
compass test his spirit guide was born
in gory georgia
i i did take the political compass test
guess what i was fascist fascist liar
your guest was a lie tommy fascist
comedy fashion tank you inverted the
whole chart do you want me to make it
explode it was um what a libertarian
left left libertarian on this one bottom
the center of the just like george soros
yeah i doubt you would i doubt you would
be comfortable with the things that get
great passes left libertarian in the bay
area oh i'm sure oh they're not they're
authoritarians that's the craziest thing
to me i always describe it like left
libertarian would be hippies on a farm
sharing their watermelon together you
know no one's exchanged there's no
there's no hard currency they have a
community and understanding and
agreement but this stuff uh left
libertarianism only really works when
you have a homogeneous culture and
ideology i used to i talked with bob
murphy about this today i used to want
to help people now i want to give them
tools so that they can help them
i want to give them the opportunity to
help themself and if they don't that's
it
i can't
force them help upon them ian's turn to
the dark side is you know i'm a gray
jedi we are both the dark and the light
that's what that's what the all the bad
guys say yeah no the bad guys all think
they're the good guys
all right man uh michael it's been a
blast thanks for having me guys for
everybody else uh smash that like button
subscribe to the to the channel you can
follow us at timcast irl you can follow
me at timcast we'll have a bonus segment
for members coming up at around 11 or so
p.m but uh do you want to shout out your
books one more time yeah sure uh go buy
my new book san francisco why
progressives ruin cities and while
you're at it by apocalypse never why
environmental alarmism hurts us all i
want to i want to thank the chat members
for the luke nukem uh comments i
appreciate those very much uh they i i
a lot of times i'm laughing here and
people are like why are you laughing
it's it's i got the chat open i love you
guys you guys are awesome uh i released
two videos today one on youtube.com
forward slash we are change and another
very spicy one on
lukeuncensored.com if you're interested
in those check those out and i'm ian
crossland thanks again michael for
coming this was fantastic and i want to
shout out uh jacob geometrics on
instagram and etsy for sending me this
thank you so much for sending this to me
man i love it that that ian gave to me
and then took back yeah luke was like
can i have this he's like yes yeah yes
and then i'm like oh this is gonna be so
cool on my wall because i wanted it i'm
posting i'm posting everything up on my
wall that you guys sent me that was in
the vlog today and then and then like
compatible and like 10 minutes later ian
comes back and i need that back yeah i
want it back i do want you to have it
though just so you know it's fine it's
fine it's a great design it is i'm glad
the world sees it yeah
and yes thank you guys for tuning in it
was really enlightening to hear more
about california and homelessness i'm
really glad michael's able to join us
tonight you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids
make sure you go to timcast.com for that
member segment and we will see you all
there thanks for hanging out bye guys
you